all right we're back yeah we don't know
what the [ __ ] happened with that why is
it so much brighter restart it
because this [ __ ] thing's [ __ ]
look at that it looks better
yeah i guess so here's something up
check the volume
no i did already you did already i guess
the volume's okay okay
because the volume keeps like turning to
two and then i'll do it all kind of like
crazy [ __ ]
i don't understand this thing we we uh
restarted the whole laptop
well i had to it froze up yeah oh it did
it froze up mm-hmm
that's that that's there's some [ __ ]
with that well that's what happens when
you buy a cheap ass laptop i guess
we have to get another laptop but the
thing about it is that this is about
when we crashed on wednesday as well i
think it was like about
40 45 minute mark and then after that it
was okay but like i said i'm not i'm
trying not to
jinx anything that laptop should have
plenty to do stream though
well yeah like i said we've discussed
this before it's
i don't know i'm mystified and i
honestly am too old to worry about that
kind of [ __ ] at this point
i just want stuff to work we're almost
up to 20 now everybody's all pouring
back in
yeah what i was saying and i'll say it
i'll go ahead and
say what i was saying he says get a mac
i have a mac but it's old it's an old
one um
what i wasn't talking about willard the
rat i was talking about
captain willard from apocalypse now he's
a good example of ptsd
and how a good man can get addicted to
to that [ __ ]
that rush of a [ __ ] mission goal
directed
violence okay or mission directed
violence
he's [ __ ] loaded off his ass in the
hotel room somebody knocks on the door
and [ __ ] two officers come in and he
rolls off and
he's just the general wants to see you
you come with there he says
it says can't we look you need to come
with us and he goes what are the charges
so he's already thinking he's in big
trouble no no
general wants to see you man you got a
new mission and he's like oh okay
and then they finally get in there get
him in there and they [ __ ] started
asking him
did you did you kill a vietnamese
officer this and that and he goes oh
i don't know anything about that mission
did you assassinate the
officer over here because i i don't know
anything about that see denying all
these [ __ ] homicides
so he had already killed four or five
people all of them
illegally that's why he was denying it
but he was ordered to do it
you couldn't say yes then they wouldn't
trust you with the mission
because you had to deny the mission the
mission didn't exist
so you know he he
he had some of that inner conflict you
know he was doing something he wasn't
supposed to be doing but that's what his
job was
they were telling him to do it yeah just
following orders
yeah well yeah the orders weren't legal
though but he was in backs
he was in matt matt v sog which was a
special
observation group it was cia and special
forces all mixed together
it was doing things that was similar to
what my unit was doing during that same
time my unit was called tiger force
you can look it up this first 327 recon
and its nickname in vietnam was called
tiger force and it was a lot like
mag v sod bit a lot of investigations i
didn't know about later on they
declassified a bunch of stuff about my
unit
it was it was it did a lot of bad [ __ ]
like
cut people's heads off and [ __ ] rape
people and stuff
it was they were out they were out viet
conging the viet cong
the vietnamese were with them the south
vietnamese when they were doing all this
stuff
they were using terror tactics against
the enemy
but they all did it everybody was doing
that that was the way that was that's
why that's a [ __ ] great movie even
though it's not
100 accurate let's see if everybody's
here okay
it's good enough now we can get back we
can get back to subject okay cool
all right so like i said we've just been
kind of doing a general thing about
yeah morose but let's kind of talk about
let's do the timeline kind of talk about
her upbringing and all that other kind
of [ __ ]
if everyone is prepared to do that like
i said since we've already been on for
like [ __ ] 45
minutes even though it doesn't really
seem that long honestly hopefully it
won't crash again but we'll see how it
goes
all right so aileen
was actually born uh
in the 50s and like her dad who she
never met
her dad's name was leo dale pittman and
he was actually
a child molester and uh also a criminal
he was actually in prison when she was
born thank you gadgey3 matrix glitched
so have to do it again did i do it
before have a stella yeah you did do it
before
but thank you anyway yeah so
he was in prison when she was born um he
actually ended up hanging himself in
prison
in 1969 so as i said
genetically maybe not the best stock
because he was
he was in prison i think he was in
prison for raping a nine-year-old girl
seven-year-old girl something like that
yeah so that was that was the dad
and her mom whose name was diane she
actually married this guy when she was
only 14 years old like she got pregnant
and then she married him
um and the first kid that they had
together was actually alien's brother
whose name was keith so he was a little
bit older than her
so diane and leo
aliens apparently parents were only uh
married about two years
and then right before aileen was born
just a couple months before she was born
uh
her mom got a divorce and like i said
she was just a kid so
uh not not real good so
basically in 1960
you know she's still a teenager she has
two
young babies and she's kind of like well
i don't you know i can't really deal
with all this situation
so she left aileen and her older brother
keith
with her parents so aileen and keith's
maternal and grandparents whose names
were laurie that was the dude
and britta warnos now
these two have their own set of problems
um they were both drunks
and laurie the grandfather was real
uh strict and real abusive
and the weird thing about it so they had
two kids of their own right so they
raise aileen and keith as their own kids
and they don't tell them
that they are not actually their parents
but their grandparents right
um and you know they're gonna find out
at some point later on and think you
know all adults are big fat liars
um and that is uh essentially what
happened so yeah so they didn't tell him
for a long time
and the grandfather like i said kind of
a drunk
i think the grandma was kind of a drunk
too which i don't kind of blame her
because
putting up with the grandpa was probably
annoying
but this was in troy michigan so
aileen didn't find out aileen and keith
didn't find out that these were their
grandparents and not their parents
until aileen was 12 years old i don't
know how she found out
but they found out somehow and uh
again she'd already been i mean prior to
that point it's like it's interesting
because if you see pictures of her as a
little girl
she's actually like a pretty cute little
girl
but i think because her grandfather
you know her home life was so abusive
like he used to beat the [ __ ] out of her
he used to beat the [ __ ] out of keith
and so i think she was kind of like
she was she had a real temper a problem
with her temper like she acted out a lot
um and they talked to i saw a
documentary about her earlier
and there was a friend of hers that knew
her like in elementary school
and she was like i think that a lot of
the other kids were kind of scared of
her
and wouldn't hang out with her and so
she'd be like sitting over there by
herself but if anybody said
anything sideways to her she would like
beat the crap out of you you know what i
mean she was like that kind of kid even
when she was like pretty little
so when aileen finds out that her
grandparents are actually her parents
that made it like way even worse because
like i said
you tell a kid your whole life hey i'm
your mom and dad oh never mind i'm not
your mom and dad
um you know that's that's gonna you're
gonna develop some trust issues
you know uh which she did
so um she had already by this point
i think when she was only 10 or 11 years
old
she kind of discovered that the only way
that people would hang out with her and
like her
was if she traded sexual favors to boys
and like i said she was 10 or 11 years
old
so she's basically you know taking boys
out behind the bleachers or whatever
letting them do whatever and then she
was doing that for like cigarettes or
you know some quarters or something like
that she was just a little kid
because i think she kind of came to a
realization earlier on that this is the
only way
that i'm going to get kids to like me is
doing this
so which is [ __ ] up i'm looking at
your boobs through my tablet
yeah yeah you're just like not helping
me on the show at all
no no i'm getting ready to make another
drink actually i wanted a drink
yeah hold on let me let you go
yeah yeah sophie sent that to me they're
saying like shirt
that's that's a club i used to hang out
at back in the 80s
in detroit called city club there's an
old golf club
you're going to get me that's empty
enough yeah
uh yeah maria makes the point rage is
associated with borderline
personality disorder yes which is what
she got um
diagnosed with later on uh she seemed to
have problems with that almost from the
beginning like i said
you know she had even though she never
met her dad
because he was in prison when she was
born and then he committed suicide in
prison later on
um you know he was a criminal
you know and a child molester so you
know not the best and like i said her
mom was only like
you know 14 15 years old when she had
her uh
so you know not not the greatest start
in life
and then she goes and lives with her
grandparents and they are also abusive
now
the thing about it too is that so not
only was aileen
kind of it seemed like she had learned
at this point that one you couldn't
trust anybody too
um the only way to get people to like
you
was either by buying them things or
offering them your body
essentially which was uh kind of the
conclusion that she came to
um she actually did say later that maybe
her grandfather had molested her i'm not
sure if that's true or not um
but i think that was one of the claims
that she made later on which like i said
it wouldn't shock me he did beat the
crap out of them and
um a lot of the abuse did have a sexual
tinge to it
so like i said it wouldn't be all that
surprising if that had happened
now so alien and her brother keith who
was a little bit older
apparently keith was the only person
that aileen trusted now
her and her brother were really close
although their step siblings said that
you know they could be really close but
then they you know fought a lot
too so it was a very tumultuous
relationship
thank you aileen also admitted later
that it was also a sexual relationship
so she did actually have
uh sexual relations with her brother
when they were both young when they were
both
kids which as i said that's
it's gross but you can almost understand
why it happened because they were kind
of like well we're
you know we're we're the only thing that
each other has so you know what i mean
thank you zach tonight's good i got back
from another date have chinese for
dinner
and my favorite show is going you look
great in white by the way jenny thank
you
i never wear white though i just i don't
know there's something about it i don't
like coffee but
but you know bride of frankenstein i
gotta do that [ __ ]
but uh but yeah so she was sleeping with
her brother
apparently um which is [ __ ] up
i don't think that's all that rare
actually well in the situation that they
were cuz i think they'd [ __ ] [ __ ]
around
well i don't never had any siblings so i
don't really know but
i don't remember [ __ ] like that when i
was a little kid
i think their situation was
you know they were in a household that
they found out when they were 12 13
years old
was not their parents but their
grandparents and that their mom had
abandoned them
um and they kind of so they kind of felt
like well me and you were like the only
ones
we can you know we're the only people
that we can trust right like
[ __ ] it was like them against the world
that's some [ __ ] out of like the roman
empire
but i was kind of thinking it was like
flowers in the attic yeah you guys like
read that it was like that kind of like
incestuous weirdness
like i said they were little kid there
were kids i mean you know there were
teens tweens whatever so it's like i'm
not gonna like [ __ ] on them for that and
like i understand um you know how that
could have happened
uh because as far as i know because i
think keith was abused as well
roman empire had some weird [ __ ] like
that going on going
on in it at all times just because uh
they were so viperous a lot of times
brother and sister are the only people
that could trust
they were only people that had any trust
for each other even within a family
you had family members royal families
the family members were killing each
other over power and [ __ ]
ligament his sister evidently that's
what was going on yeah
it was like a [ __ ] mafia family worse
than a mafia family more like something
i don't know like saddam hussein's
family
i mean like i said i think though that
this is kind of a different situation
because they were just kids and they
were both enduring the same abuse
what i was saying well there were no use
in the [ __ ] royal families of
of rome you know they were killing each
other yeah
so you know a lot of times the siblings
were the only people that trusted one
another inside the whole family
yeah and they were all locked up you
know they weren't open societies
couldn't go anywhere yeah so so you can
see how it happened like i said i'm not
excusing it
they were locked up but they were locked
up in poverty there was nowhere they
could go
yeah so as i said so aileen had kind of
gotten a reputation
goodness yeah all right it burned my
throat
yeah i wonder what that was in there
i don't know it was like bad almost like
hair you ever
had a hair hitting lead on your
cigarette and you [ __ ] take a drag
off of it no i have nothing
oh man i'm gonna [ __ ] you up okay
um yeah so as i said aileen had kind of
got a reputation
you know going back to when she was 11
12 years old around the neighborhood
that she was promiscuous
that if you wanted to do anything sexual
all you had to do was give her some
cigarettes or some change
and she would do whatever you wanted
right yeah
um so not a good situation
so not surprisingly when she's 14 years
old
she turns up pregnant um
she said that the pregnancy was a result
of
rape uh she said that the guy that the
father
was an older dude from the neighborhood
i don't know if that's true or not but
that's what she said
um so she gets sent to
uh a home for unwed mothers one of those
things that they had back then
when she gets to this home um the staff
couldn't really do much with her by this
point she was kind of like incorrigible
she had a lot of problems with rage with
her temper she would always kind of like
as i said a lot of the neighborhood kids
and some of the other kids too i think
in the home were kind of like afraid of
her
because her temper was just she would
kind of like be normal and then she
would just kind of snap and like flip
out or whatever
so i think a lot of people were kind of
bothered by that now
she ended up having a boy
um i reports differ some i think she
said later that she was just kind of
allowed to see him for a second but i
think they just like kind of took him
away
and didn't let her see him and just gave
him up for adoption
so i don't even think i never read
anywhere that she was able to
go and find him or if she ever would
really wanted to do that or anything
like that but so
she had a baby when she was 14 and they
took it
away from her that was in january of
1971
now later that same year interestingly
her grandmother britta who they'd been
living with died
now after the grandmother died the
grandfather
laurie the abusive [ __ ] was like okay
well i don't
feel the need to have these children in
my home anymore who were still teenagers
they were like 14 and 16 i think
so we kicked them both out um
keith the older brother um he just kind
of like moved down the street to his
friend's house
but aileen was kind of like [ __ ] it i'm
just gonna go off on my own
and she just started wandering around
and making money
as a sex worker because that's what she
knew how to do
you know what i mean and she was like
[ __ ] 14 or 15.
so something's in there
i'm not smoking any more of that
somebody said tom just smoked a seed
probably wouldn't see
some kind of stem yeah it might have
been
yeah that's not weed that's that's a uh
when it comes to a herbal cigarette or
just they just throw something
i can't smoke real cigarettes they've
spoken some throw some [ __ ] cut grass
inside a [ __ ] thing and like
kept burning me up every time i took
over i don't know
smoked a lot of weed when i was a kid i
don't like it
smoke some of it [ __ ] a couple years
back it was still i was like yeah i
remember that that's not
yeah i'm not like a big fan of it either
i mean you know we've kind of gone into
that before
so yeah so cheap drugs cheap drugs
well it depends on what kind you get i
mean you know some of it might be if you
get the good [ __ ]
yeah so you have to think at this stage
alien is
14 15 years old and she is essentially
left to her own devices because her
grandfather
has thrown her out of the house now i
guess at this stage
her mom diane um
i guess asked aileen and keith to come
live with her
um but they neither one of them wanted
to because like i said i guess they were
kind of like hey you abandoned us so
[ __ ] off
it was just kind of that kind of thing
so as i said aileen just kind of dropped
out of school
she just kind of took to wandering
around and
started making her money as a sex worker
now a couple years after that her
brother keith
actually ended up dying from throat
cancer
i mean he was young so he died of cancer
her grandfather what nothing no i'm
responding to somebody in the comments
okay let me do my job jenny
you're not you're not doing my job
you're not just finding a team in the
job
[Laughter]
okay go ahead no are you putting out a
show i'm listening all right
yeah so you're doing good you don't need
to interject and today we're on a
[ __ ] time
limit well we're not like on a time time
gotta watch it's coming
we have to [ __ ] we gotta do today and we
can't sit here and get loaded tonight i
gotta drive well yeah
i'm not gonna have this is my last one
i'm not gonna have another one after
this
because like i said i don't you know i'm
mostly ready all i have to do is put
shoes on and put my nails on and [ __ ]
but
you know what i mean yeah so her brother
uh who was pretty much
according to everything i've ever read
like the only person she ever like
actually connected with uh he died real
young of throat cancer
and then not too not too long after that
their grandfather
committed suicide so you know like i
said it's just tragedy after tragedy
so aileen who most of her friends knew
as
lee actually she kind of moved around
um you know she did some petty [ __ ] like
in other states or whatever but she
heads for
florida now in florida
she meets this guy who was much
much much older than her he was like an
old guy
um i mean she was only maybe in her
teens or early 20s at this point and he
was like maybe in his 60s or 70s
his name was louis fell and he was kind
of uh
well off right he'd had like um
he was president of the local yacht club
like he had made all this money from
railroad stocks and also the kind of
stuff so he was kind of like um
kind of wealthy and he for whatever
reason um
took a shine to aileen and then they got
married i don't know how long they knew
each other i kind of feel like it wasn't
really that long
uh so they get married and then
uh predictably it didn't go super well
because i guess aileen was back in
michigan doing what she did like
visiting friends or whatever
and she got into a bar fight uh
which was another common occurrence for
her she apparently threw a cue ball
at the back of a bartender's head and
got arrested
and so uh louis her husband
decided he was going to get the marriage
annulled he also said that she had spent
a whole bunch of his money
and that she was abusive toward him like
that she would
beat him with his own cane and [ __ ] like
that
and that she had anger issues so uh
the marriage actually kind of uh ended
up getting annulled
now as i mentioned her brother keith had
died of cancer
now keith had life insurance and he
actually left
ten thousand dollars to aileen
so aileen got ten thousand dollars
how long did that ten thousand dollars
last two
months she bought a car with it
and she wrecked it almost immediately
and pretty much used the rest of it for
beer and staying in cheap motels
so you know she's living the high life
at this stage
so she's kind of like i said she kind of
drifted
to colorado for a little while she was
like in michigan for a little while
but eventually she ends up back in
florida
and this is kind of this is where most
of her major crimes were
committed like i said she did commit
some [ __ ] in other places like petty
larceny and you know holding up [ __ ]
liquor stores and [ __ ] like that
but forgery uh but florida is where her
serial killing career kind of started
out
um she actually got i think she was in
prison for
i think she got a three year sentence
but i can't remember how long she was in
there
but she held up man what was it a liquor
store or a convenience store
she came in in a bikini i think
and basically like held up the old woman
behind the cattle like the gunner
yeah i think she was wearing a bikini
but she got caught for like it was like
in the middle of the day i think she was
just kind of like
i don't think she went in there
intending to hold it up i think it just
kind of was like a spur in the moment
thing
i feel aileen warnos she was not a real
um organized person i would you know
what i mean we were talking about btk
earlier and how he was like a planner
and like sometimes he would have kind of
like he had notebooks full of like plans
and
maps and [ __ ] like that so he was like
very into
stalking people it was kind of like that
was part of the fun
for him was keeping
dossiers on people and like stalking
them ahead of time and stuff aileen was
much more
um a spur of the moment kind of
[ __ ] you know what i mean
um i don't think she really thought
about anything particularly beforehand
like i said i don't think she woke up
one morning said i'm gonna be a [ __ ]
serial killer
i think it just kind of happened and
then she's kind of like whatever
she was just kind of one of those i'm
going with whatever kind of people
so so this uh hold up
that she got put in jail for a brief
time for i don't even think she was
she went in there like planning to hold
the place up i think she just went in
there and then she just decided to
you know i'm just i'm just hearing a
bikini it's like she didn't really think
about
how ridiculous that was or how easy it
would be for her to get caught or
whatever
so yeah um
so at this stage uh you know she's also
she's making most of her money i mean
she's doing like petty theft like
holding up
places and [ __ ] like that but she's
making most of her money as a sex
worker now even though she was just like
in her 20s
at this stage um she was actually she
wasn't a bad looking
uh woman when she was younger um
but you know as as time went on and she
kind of drank a lot
and you know she lived real rough i
think you know
when she first got kicked out of her
grandfather's house she was like living
in the woods and [ __ ] like that
so that's going to take a toll on your
looks you know
so i mean when she was executed she was
46 and she looked like
she looked like seven she looked like a
hundred miles a bad road seriously
i mean you know she's like a rocket not
not to be a [ __ ]
but yeah living that kind of life is
gonna take a toll on your let me let me
say something though before all right we
continue
there's a really good movie about her
and
and it had what's her name really
charlie's there
charlie starring and yeah club monster
yeah monster and little cutie girl
[ __ ] little cutie girl who played uh
uh
um you know what i'm talking about
yeah come on i'm not that drunk jenny
the girl the girl from adam's family
yeah christina ricci christina ricci
yeah she played
uh tyra who were about to talk about
right and [ __ ]
those two got so ugly from that [ __ ]
movie i really respect that [ __ ]
well she [ __ ] ended up looking like
eileen warren
charlie's there i'm pretty sure he's
gorgeous she's
cute woman she just [ __ ] ratted
herself to
[ __ ] to look like eileen warnos and i
was just like goddamn
she won an oscar for that actually yeah
i saw that movie in the theater
that was the only other time because i
remember you guys when i said that uh
martin landau playing bella lugosi in
ed wood um was the only other time
that i forgot that it was an actor
playing that part
that was the other time charlize theron
playing alien warner's i forgot that
that was not alien bornos
yeah i forgot that she was dead
christina reach while i was watching
that yeah yeah yeah she was sure
i [ __ ] got so pissed when she [ __ ]
lost weight and lopped her boobs off
because she when she was short she did
one movie where she was short and she
put on some weight before she played the
blonde girl
i don't remember the name of that one
remember when she played kind of like
she was in a seed start
and her [ __ ] boobs were big and [ __ ]
and i can't believe she got a [ __ ]
blue production
that's [ __ ] crazy that's like having
bars of gold and just throw it away
[ __ ] man every man got mad every boob
man got mad
remember that one well considering
they're not your boobs i guess it
doesn't really matter if you all got bad
movies
it's public property i mean come on man
they're in about not really they were in
the movies
i can't understand why she did that well
maybe her back was hurting
i
i don't believe that work out get some
back muscles man
or maybe she wanted some different kinds
of roles and she thought she was getting
only one kind of roles because she
was it was the thing is it's all
stereotypical [ __ ] she was
short and she was [ __ ] curvy all
right and she was cute
and she i guess she wanted to have well
i don't want to be that i want to be
able to be
anything but that was that she was
working that look
you know what i mean yeah she was
bringing that in but it does type cast
you
a little bit yeah well whatever
maybe she wanted to like do more serious
roles or whatever
dom the bomb laughing bars of gold bars
of gold exactly bars of gold bro
men understand see you don't understand
me anymore
you don't understand why you always
crying why are you crying
okay we gotta get next show he's always
crying yeah
it's not crying it is though it's
pontificating
no that's not it's not
[Laughter]
or it's at least complaining
you're like an old woman what are you
talking about like a
woman you're like a old woman just like
crying all the time
crying all the time crying all the time
all right
poor went out for the lobby she [ __ ]
picks on me constantly for being
reasonable
no that's not why i'm picking up yeah
i'm picking on you well the the fact
i think it's very funny that you think
you're being raised clearly not
of course i'm being reasonable no you're
really not but okay
[Laughter]
yeah so if you haven't seen monster i
would recommend it
it's like really really good and like i
said that was one of the one of the two
movies that i can think of where i
actually forgot that that was an actor
playing the part
yeah i mean she was amazing in that
now i like [ __ ] prometheus and
[ __ ] a lot of people don't like
prometheus but [ __ ] those people
i like to prometheus on blu-ray with the
deleted scenes and all that [ __ ] and all
that mystery and she was in that movie
too i thought she did a great job
and i know she's a fantastic actress and
i know more about that movie than these
[ __ ] that didn't like it she
was playing a replicant
i don't want to get off in that [ __ ] but
well yeah what does that mean she would
be
a replicant that doesn't have anything
to do with anything
that just had to do with yeah you know
you you just use that as a tangent
because she was in monster
and you wanted to go off in time no
we gonna have fun tonight hugo says tom
where's your costume
he's no fun that's where his costume is
oh the costumes that i have are too hot
man
for where we're going that's not a hot
out costume
i mean it's hot but i'm saying it's it's
temperature it's [ __ ] burning up out
there
yeah this is this dress in florida
pretty short it's tropical out there i
i'm not i'm not gonna dress up in some
because everything i have is based
around jackets and [ __ ] i think it's
like 87 degrees outside yeah and i'm not
going to go out there
and with 100 humidity and i'm just not
going to do it i when i was younger and
had some [ __ ] to prove
everybody knows my closet [ __ ] they
know my they know my closet's fantastic
half the [ __ ] i have is [ __ ] brocade
and velvet and i'm not wearing that
i'm not gonna dress up like a vampire
that's how cool he is he just has the
clothes but he doesn't wear them yeah
a graduate they know what i have in
there
everybody down there knows of what i
have so i don't have to
now i could be like these second
industrial [ __ ] like defense
mechanism that's that girl where you try
to remember her name defenseman that's
right
defense mechanism i couldn't think of it
on wednesday i was just like goddammit
what's her [ __ ] yeah
i could and just dress up in metal
shards and glass
and stuff that's nice and cool because
there's no no material there
plus it keeps everyone away from you so
it's a win-win but
it helps when you're a [ __ ] chick
with [ __ ] big boobs and a rocking
body you can wear next to nothing
the only way i'm gonna be able to get
away with that is in a couple more
months when i burn off a little bit more
fat
than the hrt kicking in right [ __ ]
you should have seen my sheets bro my
she
it was just a damn smudge a grease
smudge i told you when you got out of
bed the other day your feet smelled so
bad
that i was just kind of like every
[ __ ] night that hrt
[ __ ] you up like they're in the front
stunt that bad they're in the dryer
right now 14 man god damn it and it's
just like
sweating out bacon grease and [ __ ] it's
like having a 14 year old kid
yeah but no i'm gonna i'm gonna be
rocking my [ __ ] gladiator
outfit man every gay man in the world is
gonna want my autograph when that shit's
ready bro
[ __ ] zack's gonna be like tom could
you send me another pictures in the
united gladiator outfit
is it greaves and a [ __ ]
[ __ ] armored skirt no shirt and a
[ __ ] like
like a mermillo or a [ __ ] mermillo
outfit a [ __ ] helmet
or or or a secutor i'm not gonna dress
up like a [ __ ]
retiri though no i'm not gonna do that
one
okay well probably standards yeah
sorry already you had to be gay to be a
retiree
they'd said that because it's a man
it's it's a it's a man hunting
fishing for other men because he's a
fisherman here a minute
a man fishing for other men i'm sorry
we're gay yeah
sorry i'm just laughing at victor's uh
victor garcia's joke i heard charlize
theron is really meryl streep
prepping for a role
[Laughter]
love it yeah i love that joke all right
wouldn't that be something if she came
out and it was like [ __ ]
like the world's longest troll teach him
it was just meryl streep all along
yeah you should nah with the [ __ ] big
fro
yeah to throw away well you could kind
of where you could wear your michael
douglas wig
michael douglas michael kane wig uh no
you're willy wonka wig
but you have to kind of dark brown he
had
some little shorts they're telling me to
flex that crustle
oh [ __ ] yeah all right
i'm going back what they're saying zach
says tom i've already got a man in my
life why i need you and your pal ass
i'm not pale your ass is pale uh that's
because i wear pants
[Laughter]
so you do have a pale ass just the ass
part right now
i walk every day like there's a cop
really short
oh yeah i walk every day in my [ __ ]
shorts and go down the pool
i'm in florida [ __ ] i get my [ __ ]
side
i mean you get vitamin d whether you
want to or not
yeah just walking outside you get all
the sudden you would ever
need this is florida in the summer
yeah it's getting there yeah [ __ ] man
tomorrow's may tina says she's still
looking at houses and moving
thinking about moving down here stewie
come on
i've got a house right next door to me t
that's [ __ ]
i think it's for sale too i think they
want 375 for that though
maybe well two-story house i don't know
if somebody's buying it though because i
keep seeing like workmen over there
well i think the landlord's just
rebuilding it because new renters are
coming okay he's been trying to sell
that thing
t you contact me i'll give you the
address and everything mom we need
somebody
that lives nearby to hang out it's a
beautiful [ __ ] two-story house and
the upper floor looks down
on the [ __ ] lower floor so it's got
vaulted it's like
real high vaulted ceilings yeah we knew
the people who used to live there you
scored yeah because we've been in there
it's got like seven [ __ ] bedrooms and
a [ __ ] it's like seven bedrooms
it's got a bunch of got three living
rooms
and dens and a big downstairs [ __ ]
den and
and and it's got a gigantic [ __ ]
garage you could probably fit four cars
in there
um it's it's pretty nice the only the
only downside is is it costs a lot
to air condition these two stories
houses here it's good because it's
the front of the damn house is one big
[ __ ] window
the window covers two stories
yeah yeah it's a nice house though yeah
it's nice though and i think they've put
in
the size of this one it looks like they
put in all new carpet
i don't know what else they did in there
but they've been working in there i know
they put new carpet in because i thought
when they pulled the old carpet out
yeah right yeah
tila says don't tempt us tom we're
seriously looking at a few states right
now we have not ruled out florida t
says 375 we get you a tent
in the tent yeah you cannot
nothing in california equates to uh
nothing in san francisco equates to uh
to florida it's an entirely different
world entirely different i mean you can
get nicer
for pretty happier yeah you can get a
mansion for
yeah you got 375 400 000 you can get
like a really nice
[ __ ] huge house and it's in a good
neighborhood and with a lot of great
services and it's a lot of fun down here
it's it's a
it's like everything looks like disney
it all looks like an extension of disney
[ __ ]
if you get you give me a social contact
media
me social media contact i'll [ __ ]
i'll take videos of the house next door
i'll show you what neighborhood looks
like what it looks like around here
[ __ ] compared to california it's
amazing and i'm from california
california's kind of tired it's from
another era this is all brand new man
it's all [ __ ] brand new well and
there's still building stuff
all around this i mean this neighborhood
is probably 11 years old 12 years old
um but they're building new houses all
around here
so you might be able to get something
new just like right up the street and
the feel of it
reminds me a lot of san francisco
vista area back in the late back in the
70s
back in the late 70s that's what it
feels like very real open free
environment it's not aggressive or
anything
it's not there's no [ __ ] if you're
[ __ ] here it's not tolerated
you know oh i don't know about that
that's beat
down here this is nothing like you never
lived in new england
in boston you can't live there without
being an [ __ ]
a lot of [ __ ] they would do in boston
new york era even though new york's a
lot friendlier
actually than boston yeah i didn't i
didn't find but i like
new york i've been to new york lots of
times and it's like i never found it
because new york could have
humor uh people in boston dope uh
[ __ ] it up tight uh no and then they
they mouth off
you mouth off here this is a this is an
honor based society
your mouth off here you're gonna get
shot or you're gonna get the [ __ ] kicked
out of you
you respect people they respect you
that's that's
that's just how it is here lawyers don't
really run this
that's why i mean we've been at clubs
where the bartender is [ __ ] holding
the door shut there's a high-end bar and
the other side of that [ __ ] door is a
dude [ __ ] open fire
with a [ __ ] pistol on the other side
because of honor and it's not a crime
ridden area
even though people get killed and [ __ ]
it's just
you gotta watch yourself here some of
these [ __ ] are wild
now the cops don't tolerate it
they tore that dude a new [ __ ] the
police station was right behind him
well that was a pretty that dude was
pretty drunk he was drunk but
but then you know yeah the police
station is literally literally right
behind him
and he's [ __ ] shooting the building
there's eye bar
yeah there's a parking lot there's a
pizza place and then there's the police
station yeah
yeah it's just you know they have it's
it's it's a southern mentality
you do something wrong they'll retaliate
just be cool if you're cool to people
you won't have any [ __ ] problem
probably probably yeah i mean [ __ ] still
happens i mean
yeah probably yeah
i'm from here i've lived here my whole
life yeah it's cool i have yeah
it's just the places uh
like las vegas disneyland and mos eisley
all put together
uh
it's not a ruthless place by any stretch
of the imagination brazil was ruthless
that's the mirror universe that's kind
of where i
grew up in my formative years like sao
paulo brazil
even though i love that place it's a lot
softer than that
even though those are yeah i don't want
to get up on that
[ __ ] you already did i got off in this
it's kind of like california back in the
good old days that's that's the way it
feels to me
that's the closest analogy mixed with
mississippi there is a southern
hospitality and a southern honor culture
let me get the jenny doesn't notice it
as much because she grew up here
but she doesn't really have a lot to
compare it to let me get no i'm talking
about it
well i have things to compare it to it's
just i haven't lived in england
well i have a more i mean i've lived
here my whole life and i appreciate it
as much as i do
and i lived in other places so i know
what's behind a lot of the [ __ ]
yeah you know what i mean i i appreciate
it i appreciate it more than she
did i think she does i appreciate
florida
yeah it's not perfect but no place is
well i know that i'm just saying
strengths though yeah well
okay that's cool but i'm just saying
that you have to think that i
maybe have a different take on it
because i was born here yeah
and i lived here my whole entire life i
see the world through my eyes and had
well yeah yeah but you kind of think
that
that's the only way to look at things
that's the correct way
and it's not no it definitely is no it's
not definitely
no it's not it's it's i just like it i
like it here
i like some things about it but there's
a lot of things i don't like about it
like what
and like i said i don't know a lot of
things and like i said it doesn't have
anything to do with what we're talking
about you're just going off on tangent
then i'm trying to talk about the
[ __ ] show
okay and you're trying to you're making
it longer look at the show look i'm only
here
i'm like man we got a lot of [ __ ] to do
come on we're talking god damn
[ __ ] god damn i'm sure it's like my
fault but you're the one doing that
you're the one doing it damn
you're going off on you're talking about
prometheus and all this other kind of
[ __ ] it's like what the [ __ ] this
doesn't have anything to do with that
man damn you did this [ __ ] t
see he's gonna blame me he always has to
blame somebody else it's never him that
did it
all in the audience doing this sure even
though they didn't say anything about it
you done yeah i'm done all right thank
you see why she want to throw me out
there like that go ahead i'm not i'm
just out of here man
no i'm just trying to smoke this herbal
cigarette okay i'm trying to smoke
a little cigarette i gotta drive zanada
says no one who lives in florida was
born there i was
i was born i was born in daytona beach
actually it's an expanding state halifax
hospital it's an expanding state
so like i said aileen warnos most of the
people she killed and where she lived
like the hotel and everything that was
daytona beach i know
exactly where all of that [ __ ] is in the
past nobody lived here
just gotta look at it that way well i
only knew in high school
i knew one other my best friend uh
she had been born in florida she was
born in gainesville yeah
she was the only person i knew in my
high school that was born in florida
everyone else was from somewhere else
it's because it's air conditioning
before conditioning people really didn't
live here it was a [ __ ] swap
yeah i mean my parents were not born
here either but they moved here when
they were kids
you know what i mean because my
grandparents moved here when in 1958
and my dad's side they had been in
mississippi for a [ __ ] since even
before the civil war
and it's it's as hot as this and and as
as human but not as not as [ __ ]
tropical in terms
of like the overgrowth you know i mean
it was forest yeah
you could live here in that kind of heat
but just the road system and just
even though florida was more developed
than mississippi
i mean back in the day like i said
before i was born in the early 1970s but
i mean because disney wasn't even here
in until 1971 and prior to that
most of the middle part of the state
were all of the [ __ ] theme parks and
[ __ ] like that there was nothing there
it was just like swamps
victor says y'all have grits in florida
yes ma'am we got [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
i love grits got a bag of grits sitting
right over there
jenny what part of the usa did your
family come from my dad's side of the
family came from
tennessee springfield tennessee and my
mom's side of the family is from
baltimore
but they are yankee but they moved to uh
florida when they were you know when my
parents were very young
yeah so but my dad and my mom both went
to high school in daytona beach
at mainland high i went to seabreeze
those are rivals
because sea breeze is on the beach side
and mainland is on the mainland
so we hated each other
[Laughter]
i didn't care but you know what i mean i
went to seabreeze because it was right
down the street from my apartment
uh yeah so what were you talking about
all right so aileen warnos
so as i said she uh made her money as a
sex worker
she did okay i i kind of feel like at
the beginning but
you know the rougher the life is smoking
drinking
doing drugs whatever um
doesn't do much for your looks so you
know getting harder and harder to make
money doing that so
she eventually in 1986 she meets
tyra moore known as ty who was 24 years
old at the time
at a daytona gay bar and uh
they kind of get together now for a
while i kind of feel like it's
interesting because i think aileen
um this was kind of the first i'm not
really sure
if she was um just
bisexual and she just realized it at
this point or if she was just like sick
of dudes because she'd been a sex worker
for so long and she was like over it
or if she just liked tai in particular
and that was just kind of like because
it seemed like when they
met it was just kind of like in like
instant connection you know what i mean
so they started hanging out together
like all the time victor
victor look if you're gonna have grits
that [ __ ] can't be plain
you eat salt pepper butter and cheese
minimum
but you want that [ __ ] fully loaded with
bacon in there
and yeah cheese go ahead you never had
grits and they're talking about grits
yeah tila says shrimp and grits is the
shrimp and grits yeah shrimp
you and put cajun seasoning in the grits
you know get a good loaded up grits
recipe
hell yeah it's the polenta of the south
yeah it's a good canvas to paint things
like i will eat them plain
well not plain but with like butter salt
pepper on them
some people like them with sugar i'm not
a fan of that right whatever somebody
will put grape but if you put
i mean i like them too with kind of like
there's bacon in there some hard-boiled
eggs yeah a couple hard-boiled eggs in
there and then you like
with a spoon you slice off some egg and
then you get some grits
yeah it's good like that yeah yeah yeah
but yeah so uh so she meets tai
now tai at the time had a job uh and
seemed to have kind of a more stable
lifestyle than aileen did because like i
said aileen was very much
into just kind of like nomadic
sort of lifestyle she was kind of
wandered around she kind of hung out
at highway exits looking to pick dudes
up
right for money so she meets tai
and thank you victor i knew grits would
send you all off topic it always does
yeah y'all [ __ ] with us
now i want some yeah all that
carbohydrates now i feel like if we go
to
if we go to halfway to halloween tonight
and then we get a chantel after
yeah i mean she doesn't have grits but
she does have chicken and waffles
yeah last time i went to chantal so i
got to [ __ ] talk to him they over
salted that [ __ ] that catfish is very
salty
yeah it was it wasn't like that before
though it was good i said man drop those
french fries let me get a [ __ ] season
salad with that instead cause i don't
want all them carbs
and they're like yeah we can do that and
then the [ __ ] fish came and it was
too [ __ ] salty
they're making that [ __ ] up by hand
because the service is slow
it's a good idea man and and i'll tell
you what the jerk chicken is good but
man they're [ __ ] i'm gonna have to
set them [ __ ] straight
except too much goddamn salt it was it's
not usually like that but it was kind of
salty
but like i said i kind of i i keep
wanting the chicken and waffles because
i've heard they're really good but it's
just i'm never hungry enough to eat all
of that it's a lot of food
uh but i don't know we'll see i haven't
eaten but all i've had today is that
little bit it's that little bowl of
uh chickpea curry that you made yeah
that's all i've had today it was lentil
curry
lentil curry there you go um so yeah so
tai
at the time who was 24 like i said she
was working as a
maid at a hotel casa del mar which is on
a1a which
like i said that was like right where
that was
a1a the hotel was there there was um
like a shopping plaza and then my
apartment was right behind that
so i was like two blocks behind there
that's where i lived
so she picks up uh so her and ty start
like hanging out
now i guess for like for a time
they're making like pretty good money
they're living at another motel
i think they lived at the fairview motel
for a while which i know where that is
too
that's that's a real cd one the casa del
mar is actually pretty nice it's like a
resort and it's like right on the beach
that's where tai worked she didn't live
there though
you know um so they were kind of hanging
out like i said drinking beer
doing whatever um so what ended up
happening
is that ty i guess
decided or they both decided that tai
was not going to work as a maid anymore
and that
aileen who was known as lee was going to
support both of them with her uh
prostitution earnings you know so that's
what they did
the thing about it though was that as i
mentioned
because aileen was she still wasn't old
she was still fairly young at this point
but she had lived such a hard life that
she really
wasn't looking too good and maybe
couldn't attract
kind of your higher uh higher end
clientele let's put it that way
um so you know money was kind of always
an
issue so they're kind of like living
i think they had a apartment for a
little while but they were mostly just
like moving from motel to motel
uh sometimes they were homeless and had
to like sleep in the woods
[ __ ] like that so
it's around this time when aileen and
ty were kind of i don't know they
weren't necessarily on the outs but they
were having some problems uh
with money like shortage of money
because aileen wasn't bringing in enough
because like i said she couldn't really
attract
you know the higher-end clientele
anymore
so into this kind of situation
comes aliens first murder victim
now the first victim was named richard
mallory he was from clearwater
florida which is over on the west coast
he was uh he owned an electronics repair
business
now this dude richard mallory is the guy
that spoiler alert later on they would
discover
had a record for sexual assault
against minors so know that going in
but so this dude um owned an electronics
repair business
now he was even even back then by his
employees and like
everybody that you know knew about his
store or whatever
he had a reputation for closing up the
store for like days at a time
and then going off on like drinking and
prostitution binges it's like hey i'm
gonna close up the store for three days
and go
drink and sleep with hookers so everyone
was just kind of like
okay that's just what the dude does
right
so that's kind of what he did so i
so i kind of feel like he had a
reputation of doing that
and he would what he would do is he
would bring in
temp employees into his store um
to just deal with whatever orders were
pending at the time
and then when those orders were knocked
out he would just fire those people
and then he would just close the store
up and just go off drinking and horn
again
so he was that type that type of dude um
apparently also he changed the locks on
his apartment eight times in three years
which seems a little why would you need
to do that
who knows um so yeah
so all of that said just to say that
when he
didn't show up to open his shop back up
this is in december of 1989
no one was all that worried because
they're just kind of like oh
there he goes again going off on one of
his binges
uh this time though was different
so but no one reported him missing he
didn't have a wife or kids or nothing
like that that would have missed him
so uh but they found a few days after
that
they found his 1977 cadillac
um kind of just abandoned so
at that point the police kind of got
interested because why is this car here
you know obviously it was registered to
him and he had been missing
so the next one okay so december 13th
1989
which was just a few days after this
dude what do you what are you smartening
laughing all these [ __ ] in the
comment section
everybody's just talking about grits
they're talking about grits and they're
talking steven seagal eating grits
steven seagals he can't eat grits
for two reasons one he's from michigan
too he's jewish so no he's banned from
grits
jewish people jewish people they can eat
grits of course not
of course not why not they're not halal
or whatever it is they're not that's not
a jewish thing okay
what the hell are you they're not kosher
they're not kosher what are you even
talking about
grits are not kosher most jewish people
are really not that strange i'm just i'm
just talking [ __ ]
i'm just saying he uh i know steven
seagal is not
southern enough to eat grits
he's from [ __ ] michigan he's from
michigan he's yankee pure yankee
if you showed stephen yeah okay he moved
to louisiana
all right and he's running around
louisiana
pretending he's okay pretending he's
cage and pretending he's black
he's pretend but i'll guarantee you you
could look at that belly and everything
[ __ ] wasn't eating grits he
didn't get that off of grits he got that
[ __ ] off of that [ __ ] asian
experience drink
that he came out with well no one else
was drinking it so he had to drink it
all
right i love you a whole food
drink i'm gonna drink that whole pool up
that you in that pool you know guys you
know what i'm talking about
he drank the whole pool and then yeah
yeah yeah he had a [ __ ] cute asian
girl in a bikini in a damn pool for the
[ __ ] asian experience
we're gonna have a whole asian
experience me and you baby
that's how that's what he said you know
i'm gonna drink that whole pool up
just your bikini don't flavor that [ __ ]
bikini flavor
i do not want to have an asian
experience yeah help he's a [ __ ]
creep man just
he was a greek i don't think that's a
controversial opinion to have and i'm
just saying it right now
now i'm just talking i do not want any
kind of stephen's at all experience
asian or otherwise if steven seagal
ate grits when he was in in in louisiana
it was because he was trying to fit in
all right everyone else is eating my
hand
well the thing about he pretended i mean
[ __ ] man we did a whole show about
stephen segal but steven seagal
the problem with steven seagal he's a
fascinating man
well and dudes like that because that's
a type yeah
yeah these are dudes that are real um
insecure
with their masculinity and also real
insecure with their own identity
yeah which kind of ties up together
i'm good well i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna modify that but go ahead
um so they don't really know they try to
like belong everywhere but they don't
belong anywhere
yeah i got an insecurity thing i don't
think he was insecure with his
masculinity
though he was insecure okay with his
status
as a martial arts well that too but like
i said that all just kind of glides
together into because aikido is not
a real martial art like [ __ ] you know
well no martial art is a real martial
art the real martial art
is [ __ ] mma that's the real martial
art
and he could he couldn't hang an mma no
[ __ ] way
and then he was not an actor but he
talked his way into some [ __ ] in
hollywood
so he goes into this [ __ ] gig
from a position of weakness he's not
that's not akita was not a real martial
art he was not in great f he was not in
great shape
he ran like a [ __ ] he had a little
bitty arms he was a big dude he's very
tall
but he was not a big strong guy um
van damme was a lot more physically fit
arnold would have crushed him
oh he that was all in the era of the
[ __ ] mega
action star and he would have been
crushed against all those guys
and whenever he went on a talk show he
they [ __ ] asked him baiting questions
and they'd get him to lie
about his physical prowess because it's
funny
because it was hilarious and you could
tell that he was lying
because it's funny how insecure he is
and how obviously insecure it is so
that's why people ask them those
questions
because they knew that they were baiting
him and they knew that he would come up
with some um
for some reason that i can't like um you
know explain i'm super badass and like
better than these ones yeah
and they knew it and everybody knows
that they were full of [ __ ] and
that's why we didn't know there wasn't
any in the internet back then if you
just saw him on television you didn't
really get the inside joke
but everybody in hollywood was [ __ ]
taking the piss out of that dude
yeah they knew he was [ __ ] stuck up
on himself and it was really [ __ ]
insecure
so they would just get him up there and
[ __ ] it's very easy on the couch and
ask him questions yeah
[ __ ] get even in trouble that's the
thing man that's really what it is it's
very very easy
to make fun of people who are full of
themselves
yeah and don't seem to realize that and
there wasn't really anything
behind seagal really
he was a fraud he was a martial arts
fraud
and an acting fraud but he is an amazing
man
as an individual and he could [ __ ]
and because
he continued he endured all that
he even lost his career but he still
endures he makes money he makes movies
and he he could play guitar he could
actually sing
about punani about punani nanny yeah but
punani yeah he would say
and he had a television show and he had
a following
it's just amazing that he that that he
survived
and kind of prospered that he could
parlay his lameness
and he moves to russia to escape charges
but
has like a million kids this is what i
was telling you [ __ ] on another
[ __ ] program
the more crazy and toxic in them and you
are
the chances are the more children you
have he's got like 16 kids
that genome has been reinforced over and
over and over again
if you can lie if you can [ __ ]
if you can lie
you can make children also if you can
rape people you can make children what's
that
also if you can rape people you can rape
people you can make if you are a [ __ ]
highly toxic thing if you are highly
toxic
you will multiply and prosper just like
some [ __ ] out of the old testament
unfortunate yeah that's what idiocracy
is about
propagating that [ __ ] yeah that is
that has been reinforced over and over
again in [ __ ] historical genome
no one likes human genome no one likes
them
stop making more stephen singles knock
it off yeah just you know what i mean
just whoever's responsible for that i'm
i'm t's in there giving up
i'm registering a complaint giving
lessons on how to make
quiche grits and everything his dudeness
says hell yeah jenny is smoking well
thank you
yeah she's dressed up like a [ __ ]
bride of frankenstein
yeah except i don't have my shoes he
runs like barry goldberg on the
goldbergs yeah he
[ __ ] runs like what is that the
running i don't i don't understand why
he's
even i don't run that lame holy crap
yeah come on
i told the story they'd tell me to stop
hating it
he still has a following yes he does
have a follow i mean there are whole
youtube videos of like clips of him
running
and then [ __ ] d says this is because
i agree with tom
[ __ ] he says i idiocracy is a [ __ ]
documentary hell yeah
idiocracy is a documentary it's a it's a
road map of our future
that's exactly what it is stupid people
they're killing me stupid we're not
getting smarter we're getting dumber
well i don't know but well i don't know
that depends on what you mean like i
said it's a very it's a
it's a complex question yeah and the
thing about it is that everybody has
said that in every generation ever going
back thousands of years so it's kind of
hard to extrapolate i don't know
amanda marie says oh my god jenna you're
looking killer tonight thank you
thank you do a titty drop jenny shut up
okay
oh my god boob drop jenny okay
drop them where i'm just trying to make
this much somebody just
pull him up like that and try no no i'm
just trying i'm [ __ ] i'm talking
yeah you are we got a lot a lot of show
left
i know we got a lot of [ __ ] so shut up
it's almost seven
yeah [ __ ] well we still got like an hour
and a half before we even have to
think about it right the [ __ ] doesn't
even open until nine and it's only like
10
15 minutes away right and we don't have
to be there on time we're fine
we're fine don't worry they're making me
hungry about all these grits
well after the show's over maybe you can
make it that's all carbs man
well i might just have like a protein
bar or something before we leave and
then
because i want to drink on an empty
stomach well no but like i said i can
just
well a new curry there but you can i can
have a sandwich oh you know what i have
but i have all that hummus and i have uh
pita bread and i have all those
cucumbers i can make that [ __ ]
well let okay well let's just have a
cucumber and hummus sandwich and then
before we go because i don't want to i
don't want stomach to be empty but i
don't want it to be full
let me drink some protein some protein
all right so where was i after before
you went on off on your stephen cigar
uh i'm just i'm [ __ ] i'm answering the
demands of the crowd
like a gladiator in the arena are you
not entertained
yeah yeah but um
all right so as i was saying alien like
killed her first dude right
so she kills him and apparently nobody
missed the dude because they didn't
really like start looking for him until
they found his car abandoned right and
then like oh i wonder who this belongs
to
so december 13th 1989 these two guys
were looking for scrap metal by
like kind of a dirt road along i-95 in
volusia county
my home county florida and they found a
body
wrapped up in carpet so they took
fingerprints
from this body even though it was badly
decomposed
however they were able to identify this
body as richard
mallory he had been killed from
three shots with a 22.
now when they were looking into they
started investigating like why this dude
got killed
now at this point because like i said
this dude kind of had a reputation one
he had a criminal record uh for
sexual assault on a minor among other
things
he also hung out with a bottle a lot of
[ __ ] like shady [ __ ]
so no shortage of suspects as to who
might have
shot the dude um initially the cops were
going after this stripper named
chastity because aren't they all um i
feel like that's the second most common
stripper name
is it second or third chastity because
it's ironic
would have been brittany yeah every [ __ ]
was named brittany
or tiffany tiffany or britney i was
married to a champion yeah i know that's
why
[ __ ] like that you know and [ __ ] now
lindsay and kenzie
and some of the zi i kind of feel like
in the 80s and 90s maybe
cherry was the top stripper name but
chastity maybe a close second
i think i think they'd probably by the
time that cherry would have been in the
80s
that's what i'm saying yeah yeah this
was the 80s the late 80s
yeah the evolution of [ __ ] names or
candy
yeah yeah you know it's ironic when i
was i was born in 1972 my mom told me
later she wanted to name me candace
and i'm kind of like yeah you wanted me
to be a stripper there are [ __ ] tons of
candace's
lots of them yeah although it's not a
bad name
nobody calls it it's a good name it's
not like nobody's like nobody calls them
candy though
candy cane oh those thumbnails
yeah that was iggy pop and kate what's
her face from the v52s
that was a good song yeah britney irwin
says it's britney [ __ ] ugg and no one
spells it right
yeah xanada says madison is a big
stripper name
yeah that's right also the name of the
uh mermaid in splash
from 1984 just saying
um but yeah so this stripper was named
chastity and she was like their first uh
suspect for shooting this dude for
whatever reason
um but obviously it wasn't her so that
case ended up going cold they had no
idea who had killed this [ __ ]
like i said because he had a lot of kind
of shady connections or whatnot
may 5th 1990 the body of an unidentified
male
found naked in brooks county georgia
which is close to i-75 just across
the state line from florida two
22-caliber slugs found in the remains
uh the georgia bureau of investigation
didn't know who this dude was so they
just found this naked dead dude
with two 22-caliber bullets logs in the
body
and they don't know who he is
1st 1990 another
unidentified naked man found in the
woods of citrus county florida
this is about 40 miles north of tampa
florida
now this crime uh the first suspect was
a dude named matthew cocking
which holy crap that's a porn name
waiting to happen
matthew cocking uh he was the dude that
had found the body and i guess he was
like acting really weird like when the
police were interviewing him so they're
like
you're a suspect man he was like [ __ ]
shouting at them and threatening them
and whatnot
so they kind of brought him in for a
little while but they determined later
that that it wasn't him obviously
now they identified the body on june 7th
uh as david spears he was from bradenton
florida which is right around it's like
a suburb of
uh tampa so that ended up clearing
you know the cocking fellow now
he's cocking on the fellas thank you
thank you gadgey3 stewart is a stripper
name
is it what are you doing
what are some male stripper names i
don't know if stewart would be the first
thing that i would go to
i kind of feel like you know if if you
guys are
mst fans and you've seen the [ __ ] uh
what was it space mutiny were they like
that big chunk headed dude that was in
the main role and they came up with all
these [ __ ] names like
rock hard peck and [ __ ] like that i kind
of feel like those are like stripper
names it's funny how you're bringing up
tiffany right
my first wife yeah that's like a
stripper name
well her sister was a stripper all right
and her name was lindsey
and her husband my brother-in-law
was a stripper he was a male stripper
and
he he was a family business kind of well
those two
those two met in in in the french
quarter
as dancers okay and i'm trying to
remember what his name is tom also
tom the stripper yeah tom and he he was
a big
uh kind of buffed out semi-bodybuilder
guy
good looking guy well he owns one of the
best uh strip clubs down there in the
miami area
now really yeah he called me see how i
was doing and asked me if i [ __ ] want
to come work
work for him you want to go be a male
stripper no you want to
no you want okay he says dude man i need
a manager somebody to take care of this
[ __ ] placement these [ __ ] are
driving me crazy and i was like what did
they just be crazy yeah yeah these
[ __ ] are crazy man it's constant girl
problems you got to do this you gotta go
pick them up and [ __ ] then know their
boyfriends and [ __ ]
and and because he knew i was living
here this is about a year ago
asked me if i wanted to come work with a
minute and i was like no i got [ __ ]
going on here
you know i'm putting it in i told her
about the show and he's oh yeah yeah he
threw the show you thought
he saw you thought you were really cool
because if you want to relocate man
[ __ ]
you know he was i don't he might have
been talking six figures
maybe got a big old strip club down
there do you want to go work in a strip
club
it was too far south okay well yeah
miami's kind of far
yeah it was it was that was a 4-hour
drive but he was like [ __ ] he wanted
because
you know we had mutual [ __ ] stories
to tell about
our exes because he's made because he's
of course he he uh he he divorced he's
gonna have all he divorced lindsay yeah
those [ __ ] were crazy so you all
could bond over that
and then we were talking about our
inches we were talking about our
ex-mother-in-law
we had some yeah he had he had [ __ ]
crazier stories that i had
you know my ex was cute but lindsay was
even cuter
but she was [ __ ] crazy and that's why
i tell you guys i give you the
[ __ ] this good advice
don't judge them by how they look the
better looking they are the best
what this is what i'm telling you the
better looking those women are the
crazier they are
they are [ __ ] crazy because well most
of the time because they grow up
cute and they get their way forever
since they were a little kid
and they get pampered and it [ __ ] does
not age well
by the time they're [ __ ] 30 they will
drive you [ __ ] up the goddamn wall
just tell them landed there somebody up
thread said eric's is a good
uh mail stripper name i was like my
brother's name is eric and also
thank you mango i think that was uh that
said bob is a good stripper name and bob
is my stepdad's name
he's like a real old man not a stripper
as far as i know hopefully not
yeah she's talking about diabetes and
[ __ ]
then it says tom's 100 100 right
sure that's mercedes yeah that's another
one
i just i kind of feel like there was a
thing for strippers being named
chastity or cherry you know what i'm
saying i feel like that was kind of a
big thing
but this one was named chastity but she
didn't do it so
that's it's irrelevant um
so yeah so this uh unidentified body
that they
later identified as david spears from
bradenton who had been murdered
he was a heavy equipment operator and he
had last been seen on may 19th of 1990
and they found his truck after on i-75
with the doors unlocked and the license
plate
missing 30 miles south of that
in pasco county florida they found
another man's naked body
found a few miles off i-75 well let me
ask you something what's that
mango says i'm sure there's a market for
older male strippers
most male strippers are older most male
strippers are bodybuilders and a lot of
them are in their 40s
but you'd be surprised most of those
girls in their 40s too
they might look like they're in their
20s they're in their 40s
this and even jenny gets fooled one time
that old boob
girl we know that does all the cam work
and [ __ ] the gigantic fake boobs
she thought that was a girl that was
some young girl she's your age
yeah might be a little bit older but
some people can pull it off
um but a lot of a lot of a lot of the
male strippers are in their 40s 50s
but to make a living doing that you have
to be
on on your [ __ ] game they're
bodybuilders
basically and and really the money
does women get out of control with the
monies in in what is with guys
actually
do you mean women will pay those guys
but really [ __ ] dancing for other men
that's really where they make a lot of
the money well yeah it's gay because i
mean women don't usually go to strip
clubs it's like the only time they hire
a male stripper is like for a [ __ ]
bachelorette like a bachelorette party
that's pretty much the only time they
would do it
they used to have like they don't think
about it they used to have
like ladies nights at certain places you
know what i mean and they would be
packed but that was from another era
that was pre-internet era to do it now
it would mostly be male
clientele they'd be putting on shows for
mail yeah
which like i said you know you make
money yeah and those dudes are both well
like i said it was just like my needs
are straight
thank you his dude yeah yeah most of
those dudes are straight
so you know that no matter what they're
no matter what they're telling the crowd
they're straight well i mean the thing
about it like i said it was just like
when playgirl magazine first started
yeah and they kind of originally
conceived it as oh we're making like a
women's version of playboy
women didn't buy that [ __ ] that's for
men why would a woman buy
a magazine of like a bunch of half naked
dudes no woman would buy that
well hardly any i bought what i bought
one once as a gag gift for somebody but
i think that was the only time
women don't spend money on porn um why
would you
yeah it's it's not a woman women aren't
as visual as guys are
it's just i mean some do but like i said
i in general
women like if you're gonna buy anything
like porny you're gonna buy like erotica
yeah that's like a story yeah something
you read yeah
you don't want like pictures of children
and they're gonna use their imagination
and [ __ ] yeah
imagine it men don't have imaginations
yeah obviously they obviously don't know
[Laughter]
not for that it's a primitive sex drive
it's just very what does this look like
what's it look like
and that's kind of like this that's as
far as it goes yeah what does it look
like
it looks good it's good
very funny oh yeah i'm so simple but
yeah
all right so we know we know how yeah i
know we know how it works
women like penthouse letters they are
kind of funny
all right so yeah so we found another uh
naked man's body well i didn't find it
but you know i'm just saying that
we the royal we uh found another naked
man's body
few miles off poisonous yeah okay yes
okay um so this body discovered june 6
1990 uh very very badly decomposed
uh the emmy was not able to obtain
fingerprints
and could not estimate time of death
however
they were able to determine that this
dude had been shot nine times
uh they found nine bullets in the body
uh the bullets were uh you know it was
kind of decomposed
obviously because it had been a while
but they did figure out that it was from
a 22 caliber weapon
at this point they're kind of starting
to think
well probably maybe this is the same
killer
now this dude was actually later
identified
as being a man named charles carskadon
um but you know at the time they didn't
know
so they called the georgia bureau of
investigation because they had heard of
another
case up there and um you know they
at this point like i said they're
they're starting to think because at
first
when you just find a random dude
dead and particularly the first dude
that got killed that kind of had some
real shady
connections and whatnot you're not
initially thinking
serial killer you're just thinking he
pissed the wrong guy off and some guy
just like [ __ ] shot him right
sleeves and cheese is in the [ __ ]
comments going i find my girlfriend's in
mexico that's the inside joke
i'm sitting in the house one time i get
a [ __ ] live stream coming from
sleeves and cheese
he's in a mexican brothel streaming some
girl sitting on a couch she's like
should i hit this one yeah yeah okay
yeah get that one she's cute
i hear him cut the deal and everything
for this [ __ ] chick
i thought he was going to take the
camera into the [ __ ] back room
and give me a shot of him [ __ ]
stealing the deal bro you should have
left that [ __ ] [ __ ]
are you guys even allowed to do that she
didn't seem to mind i know the camera
would be because it's like free
advertising she was cute
she was sitting her [ __ ] half dressed
ass right up in the front window
he walked by and goes yeah i'm gonna get
this one he goes in there she's cute
probably 22 23.
well there you go he's friendly to him
he looked like the only one in there at
the time though
[ __ ] then some dude was trying to
[ __ ] hit him up for money for
introducing him
there's a middle man tried to make some
bucks off his gringo ass
sure it was [ __ ] funny man well talk
some more about yeah
about talking about hookers your porn
adventures wouldn't a porn adventure
or whatever it wasn't a porn adventure i
just
yeah you just never can't tell what will
happen on this channel
you got guys all over the world trying
to show me their [ __ ] debauchery and
[ __ ]
looking i've become like the king of
these debauched [ __ ] like
tom look what i'm doing hey tom look
what i'm buying
hey tom you want some of this i'll send
it to you just [ __ ] you guys
you need to stop offering me [ __ ]
this crazy [ __ ]
because you're gonna get my ass in
[ __ ] trouble on messenger
you know they watch all this [ __ ]
i know it's cool i don't care
i don't care if it's [ __ ] women or
anything that's legal but stop trying to
send me [ __ ]
illicit substances and [ __ ] okay you
can't send that [ __ ] to me all right
and you can't talk about them you guys
are [ __ ] crazy
yeah xander says mexico's lit yeah
mexico looks [ __ ] cool
it it's not the way it was when i was a
kid i remembered it
looking back in the 70s and 80s tijuana
was a [ __ ] joke
but uh it was like yeah we're going to
tia one it was like a gag
but you know [ __ ] khan lives down
there and [ __ ] sleeves and cheese
goes there every day you know if he
works over there and [ __ ]
it looks [ __ ] fun man kind of like
the way brazil was
i love brazil
see what everybody's talking about
megan says we should open strip club
trip clubs are a thing of the past i
think
i don't think they're going to last much
longer
he said we should open strip club i
think strip clubs are basically a thing
of the past
i don't i don't really think they'll you
might have a few in places like
vegas and and florida but
internet internet and streaming is going
to take over all that
well i mean yeah you know people can be
lazy it's like why should i
watch when i can just i can just
livestream a stripper right here
and talk to her you know now i got guys
going [ __ ] centers and
tom there's this mexican girl i'm
looking at i'll send you a picture you
can see if she passes your test
yeah bear [ __ ] i got good taste in
central and south american women
i [ __ ] like south american women
that's what i grew up with you know
brazilian girls
you know you know this is just a
different deal
yeah well they're they're
getting sidetracked it's different not
you it's a different culture it's a
different culture it's a different
it's it's just a different way and
they're they're very [ __ ] feminine
that you know
in kind of like the mirror universe kind
of way they're
also a little bit ruthless
jenny's face right now lol yeah yeah
yeah well you know
yeah you guys only get it a few hours a
week i have to put up with this 24 7.
that you're saying tell us about the
culture start from being dude that's
another show i don't have time for that
well yeah that's the joke yes yeah yeah
yeah
that's the joke everything on the
internet now right yep
all right so where was i so at this
point like i said at least get me let me
get through my notes
so tomorrow i don't wake up and go i
didn't even finish my [ __ ] you're
halfway
through pretty much well sorry almost
yeah
all right so at this point uh aileen
spoiler alert has killed like a bunch of
dudes
but nobody is really like uh you know
twigged onto that fact yet
because like i said why would you think
like a woman like a prostitute was going
around like killing [ __ ] it
just it doesn't happen all that often
so july 4th 1990
uh a car veers off state road 315 near
orange springs florida not too far from
here
and uh kind of landed in the bushes
now this woman named rhonda bailey was
sitting on her porch
watching this [ __ ] happen uh and she
said
that the car like crashed into the
bushes or whatever kind of [ __ ] the
car all up and then these two women
get out of the car like holy [ __ ] uh
throwing beer cans into the woods
and swearing at each other so
this woman says um she's like basically
there were two women she's like the the
smaller one kind of wasn't saying
anything
the big blonde uh had her had kind of a
cut or something on her arm and it was
bleeding
and she was the one kind of talking now
she saw
rhonda sitting there on the porch this
big blonde who was spoiler alert like i
said alienware knows
she said please don't call the police um
my dad lives just up the road
we're going there um so
her and ty because that's who it was get
back in the car
uh the windshield was smashed and it had
a bunch of other damage
uh but they actually managed to get the
car kind of out of the brush
um but the vehicle was kind of [ __ ] up
so it didn't really go that far
so they ended up having to leave it just
down the road and then they started
walking
now at this point like a dude named
hubert hewert
hewitt of the orange springs volunteer
fire department
um he had gotten a call about the
accident somebody had called about it
and um so he kind of came up next to the
two women who were walking
and said hey were you guys the one in
the car you know are you okay
at this point aileen uh starts swearing
at him and says no that wasn't us we
don't need help could
you know essentially [ __ ] off that's
what she said so he was like okay my bad
and he just kept on driving
now at this point marion county
sheriff's deputies
found the car where it had been
abandoned uh this was a 1988 pontiac
sunburned sud sunbird gray with four
doors
uh so as i said the windshield was
smashed also the glass in the front uh
doors was smashed
and there were a bunch of blood stains
in the car as well like on the inside
and also the license plate was missing a
little fishy
so uh the cops ran a search
on the vin number now they found out
that this car
belonged to a dude named peter seems or
simes
i'm not really sure how to pronounce
that sorry dude um
and this dude had disappeared on june
7th
after leaving his house in jupiter
florida to visit relatives in arkansas
so you know suspicious
so this dude peter seams or simes
was 65 years old he was a retired
merchant seaman
and he was in a christian outreach
ministry much like btk
was um so
basically so they said it so at this
point they're like okay well these two
women
reportedly were driving a car that had
belonged to this dude who has been
missing since june 7th
um and then a little less than a month
later these two
women crash it into a bush and then
pretend
that they didn't that they weren't in it
so that's a little suspicious
so they put out an apb on the two of
them they have like a description and
they have
you know people like draw up the [ __ ]
like what they look like and why not
so uh so they send the kind of a whole
layout of the case
sketches of the two women to the uh you
know kind of the
activity bulletin whatever they have so
they're kind of like hoping that maybe
maybe
uh this peter seems dude or simes uh who
owned this car would eventually turn up
alive although spoiler alert as i said
that would not be the case
now the next dude that was killed was a
dude named troy
beres now he was a sausage
salesman like he worked for gilchrist
sausage
and i guess he had a route so i'm
supposing he went to like various
grocery stores and you got so many studs
out there thinking they're sausage
salesmen you're a sausage salesman
that's what i was thinking too when i
read about this i was like xanada you
you're a [ __ ] sausage salesman aren't
you bro
all you all you [ __ ] out there
mangoes the sausage sale filling your
sausage
okay what's going to be i'm going to be
a street pharmacist
sausage salesman sure yeah okay
blazing cheese is asking i can't
remember was the girlfriend ever
arrested
actually she wasn't because
i think that they just kind of let her
skate because she agreed to
one uh she was the one that got ealing
to confess and two
she testified against her so i think
they
i mean because i kind of think she knew
what was going on but i don't know i
don't think she was involved directly
i think she only knew like after the
fact you know what i mean and then she
just didn't turn her in
she did kind of say that later so
sausage salesmen up to you know what
they'll make fun the dude's dead
so the sausage salesman troy burress so
he was on his delivery route
uh from gilchrist sausage now this was
july 30th 1990.
so he went on his route but he didn't uh
come back
to work so the manager thought that was
odd
and starts calling around and he said
that
um you know he called out like all the
stops on his route and all the you know
people
said you know yeah he didn't show up
like to his last several stops for that
day so
the manager of the plant and her husband
that night they go out and start looking
for the dude
but they can't find him so two o'clock
in the morning
troy burress's wife actually reported
him missing
two hours after that marion county
sheriff's deputies found his truck
left on the shoulder of state road 19
well i'm very familiar with that because
that goes out to ocala where my mom
lives
20 miles east of ocala i know exactly
where that
is the truck was unlocked
and the keys were missing obviously troy
burress was missing
also they didn't find his body
until five days later there was a family
and they were
out on a picnic in the ocala national
forest
which like i said we've been my mom
lives out there so we've been out there
a lot of times
they were um looking for a picnic spot
like in a clearing
off of highway 19 and they found his
body about eight miles away
away from where his truck had been found
um obviously this is florida and it's
[ __ ] july
so the body was real decomposed because
it's real [ __ ] hot outside only takes
a few days
yeah and like i said july and august are
the hottest i'm turning
it's just steak soup ridiculous yeah i'm
i'm surprised about
some [ __ ] moving maggots just in
about a minute oh i'm sure three or four
days
just yeah picture that [ __ ] gross i'm
sure it was like really nasty
they had to identify him because they
couldn't get any fingerprints obviously
because he was
totally decomposed his wife however did
identify his distinctive
wedding ring nothing you could say
distinctive odor no
well yeah that's him after everybody
dies they pretty much all smell this
yeah
pretty much all smell the same no she uh
she identified him by his uh wedding
ring
so he had actually been killed with two
shots from a 22 caliber gun just like
the other victims
one to the chest one to the back now
again i don't know if they were
initially thinking serial killer on this
because this is not
your traditional serial killer mo one
serial killers are usually dudes and
they usually target
women and they usually don't shoot them
they usually
do they usually stab them or do
something because that's more like
sexually exciting for them
you don't usually hear of a female
serial killer that's just shooting dudes
and not mutilating them or anything like
that that's it's very very unusual so
that's not
so i'm not blaming the cops for like for
that not really coming to their
you know coming on their radar because
why would you think of that
yeah it's it's almost unheard of
actually if it wasn't for alienware that
would be unheard of
um which is why they didn't figure it
out so they um
so for this particular crime they
thought that it was this dude
named curtis blankenship who was like a
drifter and he had actually the reason
they thought it was him was because he'd
been hitchhiking on highway 19 the same
day that troy burst disappeared
and he got picked up not by troy buress
but he got picked up on that same road
like by
a truck and so they thought well he was
in the area
like right around the time where the
dude would have died and blah blah so
maybe it was him
but you know obviously later they found
out that it wasn't
but they didn't really have any other
suspects like i said nobody suspects
that it's a woman going around shooting
dudes because that bear rarely happens
so all right so next victim that we're
talking about
is dick humphreys now
he had been working his name is dick
humphreys
i'm sorry you guys i don't know i guess
now we got dick humphreys
i know tina says uh jenny we need a
female serial killer episode i think we
did one
i need to do i wanna i've been wanting
to do another one though because like i
said
i want to do a show about amelia dyer i
want to do a show about well i mean we
did angels of mercy we did
i mean there's not as many and i kind of
feel like most of the female serial
killers like i said
are usually people that i mean we did
belle gunness
yeah she was honestly if we're going to
talk about female serial killers she was
the the only one that i could think of
that was similar to aileen warno's
because
belle gunness was a completely
practical serial killer in the sense
that
she was like hey you know i have a farm
and all this money
and i'm looking for a dude to marry me
to like join our fortunes and then when
you got there
she would just like make you cash some
checks and get a life insurance polish
and then she would just like bump you
off and bury you on the [ __ ] farm
they're in there fighting over food
right now y'all need to knock it off
about fighting over short easel
look charizo is good if you guys don't
know what that is if you're up there in
the honky motherland
chorizo is a like a hispanic mexican
spanish
mexico has it spain has it it's like
it's a latin sausage it's good it's it's
red
though um goya makes a
vacuum i want to say this to my
survivalists out there
goya makes a pack a [ __ ] chorizo it's
red
it's vacuum packed that'll keep forever
ever we'll put like
like five links of chorizo in there it's
good you can eat that with
grits you could which is shelf stable
real good with eggs
powdered eggs you can dice it up fry it
put it in a make it a burrito
tacos whatever you want chorizo is a
good one
real good and then they're fighting over
[ __ ] mexican or spanish
they're both good i've had them both
honestly it's all good
where i'm at right now it's easier to
get spanish stuff because gloya
goya sells it but they sell packaged
just like an mre so if you ever need a
combat ration
goya show diesel there's your protein
it's only like a couple bucks too
uh walmart has it yeah okay all right
i'm done duh i was food pontificating
hugo says jenny what was the name of the
countess that killed that
killed maids and bathed in their blood
count as bathroom
erzebet yeah yeah
and we don't know exactly what she did
yeah
it's hard to determine because i kind of
feel like she was probably a shitty
human being but i
i kind of feel like maybe some of the
[ __ ] was exaggerated after she died
perhaps
there may have been a motive to steal
her land
there's a lot of that [ __ ] going on back
there um she was accused of
lesbianism which may have been a motive
to [ __ ] steal her land
it's difficult to say yeah i mean
that's the thing you you have to think
too it's just like kind of the witch
trials
right you know how many as women were
just like weirdos or how many of the
women were just kind of like hey we just
want to like take your [ __ ]
you see uh in that era especially in
that in that place
a woman's existence really depended on
her husband
yep her husband was dead her husband had
a lot of [ __ ] land
it could have been some other men in the
surrounding area that said man we want
that land we got to get rid of that
woman
yeah because she doesn't have a mandolin
yeah and then they would go like well
you know she is a lesbo
and [ __ ] she's with this woman that
dresses as a man
we can use that against her if that
really happened i think it did
and then they said you know there's all
these missing women let's just say she
killed him
we'll get a corrupt priest go down there
with some guys and we'll make up a story
and say that we found all these yeah i
mean it could possibly be
she didn't really do it could have been
a total hoax
i mean no way that would not shock me it
would not win no one
although i lean towards she did it
i leaned towards she was she maybe did
something but i don't think it's kind of
like a thing where
you know it's kind of like a vlad the
impaler situation where it's like she
probably
did something but i kind of feel like
[ __ ] about her got
wildly exaggerated yeah and it's just
feelings she's saying feelings
and that's really all we can deal with
because the information is not there's
not enough information
and you don't know if you can trust it
uh evidently over there in balakia or
hungary where was it i think it's called
hungary now
where that i don't even think it's
called hungary anymore it's not even
hungry okay
i don't know where that is nowadays a
lot of the borders had changed over time
to the names of the countries
evidently her um diary
is still in the state archives but they
won't let anyone read it and it makes
you wonder why
maybe because well either maybe because
there's not [ __ ] in there yeah he didn't
do anything
and they just made it all up yeah so we
just don't know possible
and we only have the words of the
investigators
and we don't know how credible they
and it was so were ago that i don't
think we'll ever determine
that's the problem you know i mean
people can be accused of all kinds of
[ __ ] crazy-ass crimes and they'd be
totally innocent
it's happened many times yeah well and
the thing about it is that it happened a
lot more back then because there wasn't
really any way to like prove [ __ ]
you didn't really have to prove [ __ ] you
didn't you just had to have to put out a
story
there was no proof you didn't need it
and as long as everyone bought it they
was kind of like yeah suppose so
yeah okay so we don't yeah burn her at
the stake or
wall her up they walled her up alive
actually
but yeah so uh so yeah we were talking
about the next victim
and then everyone got all twitter
painted when i said that his name was
dick humphreys
sorry that's his name so he was the next
victim
so uh he was actually this makes me sad
because this is kind of like you know
one of those movies when they say
they're only one day away from
retirement and then they get killed like
in the cup buddy cop movie
okay so dick humphreys he was at his
last day of work
at the sumterville office uh he worked
for the florida department of health and
rehabilitative
services he was actually um he was an
investigator and he looked into like
uh abused children cases now he wasn't
retiring he was just moving to the ocala
office but it was his last day at the
sumterville office
he was 56 years old he was actually a
previously had been
a police chief in alabama he had also
been married to his wife for 35 years
and i believe that they had celebrated
their wedding anniversary just the day
before
he disappeared um because that was
september 10th and yet he disappeared
september 11 1990.
now on the evening of september 12th his
body was found
in marion county he had been shot seven
times
again uh by a22
um they found his car later on
in suwanee county
now about a month after that they found
another
naked male body this was walter antonio
now he was found on a logging road in
dixie county
he was 60 years old a truck driver
and he had also worked as a security
guard and was in the reserve
police he had been shot four times with
the 22.
he was found on november 19th when he
was found
he'd been dead for less than 24 hours
his car was found
five days later on the other side of the
state in brevard
county now at this point
finally i think uh the cops finally were
like okay i think
all of these crimes were committed by
the same person because like i said the
caliber
of the pistol was the same in every
single case it just seemed like a very
similar you know kind of [ __ ] now
at this point too uh to their credit
the cops were kind of like okay now
nobody hitchhikes anymore
really this is 1990. um so
obviously these dudes
are picking because they're getting
killed in their own cars
so i said they're picking up and if no
one's hitchhiking
then obviously they're picking up
somebody that either needs a ride or is
a prostitute
so at this point they're kind of like uh
we're maybe looking at
a woman that is doing this
and then they were thinking back to the
accident
with the two women that had run away
from the car that had
they found it later belonged to peter
seams who was uh one of the victims
so they're like um we need to look for
these two because this is
the most likely scenario that we're
looking at right now because like like i
said it's
because no one hitchhikes they're like
even if someone was hitchhiking
a dude would not pick up
another big scary looking dude it's like
they're obviously either gonna pick up a
prostitute or they're gonna pick up
somebody that is not
that they don't perceive as any threat
to them so again they thought it was
uh a woman so
uh so they go to the press uh the press
releases
the um you know the sketches and all
that other kind of stuff and are like
you know kind of they're kind of like
soliciting the
public for information so the leads
start coming in
mid-december um the cops have a bunch of
tips
and um a bunch of the tips are referring
to
aileen and ty although that's not always
what
people thought their names were so this
dude
in homosassa springs which i think is
over on the west coast if i remember
correctly
um he said that these two women that
were in the sketches had rented a
trailer from him
about a year prior and he said that
their names were
tyra which you know was was her name
tai and lee which was what aileen was
known as
there was also a woman in tampa who said
that the women had worked at her
motel south of ocala she said that their
names were tyra moore which was tai's
real name
and susan blahoveck which
was an alias that aileen sometimes went
by
although they didn't know that until
later they also had an anonymous person
call in
uh and say yeah i knew those people
they bought an rv for me in homosassa
springs
and their names were tai moore and lee
blahbeck
and this person also said lee was the
dominant one
and that she was a truckstop prostitute
and
this caller also said that the that they
were lesbians
now um so at this point
somebody calls in or like they're kind
of investigating some tips that they got
from port orange
uh which is a little bit south of
daytona beach i've been there many times
many of my relatives live there
so at this point they had kind of
tracked down where these two women were
they were kind of like watching them um
what they think happened was that the
couple was staying
at fairview motel like i said which is
kind of like a shitty
you know if you see the motel i don't
even know if it's still there anymore
but i remember passing it many times
it looks like a [ __ ] flop house type
of hotel
um so they'd kind of been living there
off and on
so aileen had registered there under a
pseudonym
and her pseudonym was cammy marsh green
now they lived in the motel and then for
a little while they moved into this
other apartment that was behind a
restaurant that was kind of near the
hotel but then they kind of ended up
like living back at this
like shitty motel they left there in
early december
um but then aileen came back by herself
and stayed there until december 10th so
they run
a driver's license and criminal record
information
on tyra moore and the pseudonyms
which they didn't know at the time susan
blahaved blahovek
and kami marsh green now tyra
better known as tai didn't have any uh
records she had like some minor like
breaking and entering [ __ ] but like the
charges had been dropped that was way
back in 1983 she didn't have a record
otherwise
now under the name susan blahveck
aileen had a a single trespassing arrest
her other alias cammy marsh green
had no arrests record at all uh
however when they looked at the driver's
license
for susan blahoveck um
the the two licenses didn't match like
the picture wasn't the same
so they figured that this was obviously
pseudonyms of someone else
so they go back to the green id
and did a deeper dive on that so
in volusia county which like i said
that's where daytona beach is that's
where i'm from
they chucked around in a bunch of pawn
shops and they found out that in daytona
beach
someone going under the name cami marsh
green had pawned
a camera and a radar detector and
i guess at the time to pawn something
you had to leave
a thumbprint so they found the records
they ran the thumbprint and they found
out
too that these items that were in the
pawn shop had belonged to richard
mallory
the first victim of alien warnings
this was in ormond beach so she had
pawned a bunch of she had also pawned a
bunch of tools that belonged to
another victim david spears and like i
said left her
thumbprint on the thing because that was
like the that's the law
so they run the thumbprint um and they
actually they did a computer search but
they didn't find anything right away but
because they thought
there must be something going on because
two victims
you know [ __ ] had been pawned at this
particular shop
they're like okay well there has to be
something to this so they actually went
to volusia county went through all the
records by hand
and they found um
a match now the match was to
a weapons charge uh which had an
outstanding warrant however that
person's name
was laurie grody so like i said alien
warnos i feel like maybe a lot of people
don't notice because i don't even
remember this aspect but she went by a
bunch of different aliases
so and she was arrested under a bunch of
different names
so yeah so so that matched the name lori
grody so they kind of look into that
they also uh found a bloody palm print
inside peter seems sunbird which was the
car that the women had
crashed into the bush and that also
matched
prince belonging to someone named quote
unquote laurie grody
so they send all this to the
international to the national crime
information center
and at this point they get pings from
elsewhere in florida they get things
from colorado they get things from
michigan
other like um you know arrest records
and they all turned out to be
yes who aileen carol warnos those were
all her
aliases but obviously same fingerprints
so at this point they know who they're
looking for so they decide they're gonna
do
kind of like uh we'll stake out
so they start looking early january 1991
they have a couple
uh pairs of undercover dudes and
they pretended they were going by the
names bucket
and drums and they said that they were
drug dealers
uh from georgia and they started kind of
like casing the streets
around daytona beach looking for aileen
so uh they actually spotted her three
days after they
started their little uh you know
undercover [ __ ]
they found her at a pub in port orange
now
what ended up happening okay so i guess
there wasn't a lot of communication
between some of the different like law
enforcement agencies at this point
because like the undercover dudes were
like okay
we're gonna like find her and we're
gonna kind of pretend that we're drug
dealers
and we're going to get information out
of her and we're doing this slowly right
well i guess nobody told the port orange
police
because the undercover dudes are there
trying to work their magic or whatever
and then like the port orange cops show
up and they don't arrest her but they're
like hey
uh ma'am we need to talk to you outside
and like the undercover officers are
like [ __ ] me they're gonna like [ __ ] up
the whole thing right
so what they did so they're like so the
undercover guys are like calling the
poli
the port orange like police been like
hey dude we're like right in the middle
of a [ __ ]
you know stakeout or like an operation
or whatever so like back off right
so they said don't arrest her like don't
do anything so
they finally got word back to the cops
and um
the cops didn't arrest her they were
just like oh you know sorry ma'am
whatever it was just somebody else or
whatever so she goes back into the bar
uh none the wiser so at this point uh
the two undercover cops
start talking to her uh they buy her a
bunch of beers
um you know try to get her talking they
they wanted her to like admit to
something
now they tried to give her a ride but
she said no
and she left about uh 10 o'clock so
i don't know if she knew that they were
cops but she was for sure like super
suspicious
of people which like i said we'll kind
of come up a little bit later on
so at this point they have two other
dudes
who are uh in the florida department of
law enforcement and they're
kind of following her down uh ridgewood
avenue
which like i said i know where that is
as well that's kind of where that's
where the porn theater used to be that's
where some of the strip clubs were
that's where judy's jazzy boutique was
uh you know so it's kind of like that's
where all the hookers hung out
so they're following her down ridgewood
avenue
uh in their car like with their lights
off
and so at this point they were going to
like stop her too because
everybody knows who she is at this point
right but you know the undercover people
are like no man just like let her go
where she's going to go we want to see
how this develops
so they let her go where she was going
so she ended up going to this biker bar
like i said i know where that is too
called the last resort very famous
biker bar which i don't know if it's
still there but it was there for a long
time afterward and
like i said alien wernos is like their
most famous that's like their claim to
fame
so they have like murals of her like all
of like somebody painted all over the
walls
with her quotes and [ __ ] like that it's
crazy um
and they'll talk about her like if she
shows up it's like i said it's one of
the things that makes him famous
so she goes to the last resort the
undercover cops get there buy her more
beers
kind of try to get her talking whatever
now
apparently so they talked to her a while
and then they offered a ride again she
said no and she ended up sleeping at the
bar like i said she which she did quite
often they had a cough in there you
could sleep in if
that was your thing um also they had an
old like seat out of a car
you know one of those big like bench
seats or whatever they had like that out
in the back
and uh they let people sleep on their
you know if they didn't have any place
to go or if they were too drunk to go
home or whatever so that's where she
slept
she slept on the old car seat behind the
last resort
um and this was sadly her last night of
uh freedom
because she would be arrested the next
day so the next afternoon
uh the undercover cops going by the name
of bucket and drums like i said
uh they had transmitters on and they
kind of went back and
went back to the last resort alien was
still there so they were kind of like
talking to her you know telling what was
going on
um now at this point they were actually
planning to arrest her
but the last resort as i said is kind of
a biker bar
um you get a it's a dinky like trashy
dive kind of place
but during bike week biketoberfest you
get like
thousands and thousands and thousands of
[ __ ] there and they set up
outdoor stages they have like [ __ ]
big outdoor barbecues they have all this
kind of [ __ ] going on
so that's what they were doing there at
this point they were doing a barbecue
all these bikers showed up and whatnot
so at this point they're like okay well
um should we
oops i knocked his glasses off um should
we arrest her before all this [ __ ]
starts
and they're like yeah go ahead and do it
so
um so basically the two guys stepped
forward and said to her it's like hey
look we're undercover comps you're under
arrest
now they didn't tell her at first they
said she was just under arrest for
the weapons violation they didn't tell
her she was under arrest for murder
because they didn't want her like
freaking out or whatever
um so they arrest her they said hey if
you want to come back to our motel room
and get cleaned up you can so she did
that
so they took her back to their hotel and
uh she got all cleaned up and then they
took her
uh in so as i said they did not tell her
that she was being arrested for murder
they said it was for the outstanding
warrant
under the name lori grady was a weapons
violation they said that's what you're
being arrested for that's what we're
questioning for you so
you know so she wasn't overly alarmed
they didn't want her like flipping out
on them
um also they were still looking for tyra
moore
who in the meantime had kind of taken
off so they were still looking for her
because they didn't know if she was
kind of an accessory to the crimes if
she knew anything about them so they
were still looking for her as well and
they wanted to kind of keep all their
options open
so january 10th they ended up finding
tyra moore
she had actually left florida i guess
her and uh aileen had
sort of had a falling out and um yeah
but a little bit
and um tai had taken off she was
actually staying with her sister in
pennsylvania
um so what they did was they sent a
couple cops i dropped
your glasses out yeah but i don't know i
see them i don't know where they went
yeah they're there
so they fly up to uh to pennsylvania to
interview her
now when they get up there they they
render her right her miranda rights or
whatever but they didn't charge her with
anything
so they basically said um we want you to
give a statement
like we don't know how involved you were
with
the crimes um but
you know we we're listening to what you
whatever you have to say we want you to
make a statement
so at that point you know after they
told her like you know don't perjure
yourself you can get in trouble blah
blah so ty
says okay she said i
knew about the murders since the first
one she said ever since aileen came home
with richard mallory's car which and
richard mallory was the first victim
she's like ever since she came home with
that dude's car um
i knew that she was killing people um
and aileen had actually told her
allegedly that she had killed a dude
that day
but ty apparently told her don't tell me
anymore
she didn't want to be involved in it she
didn't want to be a party to it
she was like you just do what you do but
i don't want to hear about it that's
basically what she
told her um so
she did say that sometimes uh aileen
would come home
and say you know she'd come home with a
bunch of money or with a new
with a different car or something like
that and she'd be like hey i killed this
dude to get it
and ty be like i don't want to know
that's all she would say so she didn't
want to know about it so she did
actually know that alien was killing
people
but the the issue that tai had
was that i guess um
she said that the more i knew about it
the more i felt like
i needed to report her and i didn't want
to
report her because i loved her so i
didn't want to reported the police
even though i suspected
that she was killing people you know
what i mean she didn't see her kill
people
apparently but um aileen did tell her
that she had killed people
and i i guess she didn't really have any
reason to disbelieve her
but she didn't want to report her so
she just was kind of like yeah i know
nothing she just didn't want to know
about it that's basically the route that
she took
um she said too at the time
that she was a little bit afraid of
aileen that aileen had a really bad
temper
that if aileen had killed other dudes
um you know had killed dudes being angry
at them she's like what would happen if
she got angry at me maybe she'd kill me
as well i don't really know
so that was another excuse that she gave
that she was
afraid of her tea and the british people
in there fighting over guacamole
brits if you've never had guacamole
because you can't get it
in [ __ ] bread in britain there's a
lot of recipes tea will show you one in
there
if you can't if you never had guacamole
you're just [ __ ] up
it's a cool it's a cool condiment you
put on chips you can put it in
tacos burritos whatever you want it's
cool and creamy
with a it's it's a little bit spicy not
much it's avocado tomato
garlic some spices a little bit of a
little bit of onion
it's just you just can't beat it
waka is a [ __ ] avocado in spanish
wakka
mole means sauce it's it's avocado sauce
that's what it means guacamole
[ __ ] fantastic i love i showed
brazilians
because brazilians have avocados when i
lived there i showed brazilians
how to make guacamole they [ __ ] loved
it loved it they
started eating it this is back in the
80s i mean guacamole is
good you can just eat it on like
tortilla chips yeah you don't even need
to like add anything to it back in the
80s a brazilian didn't have never even
heard of guacamole they didn't know what
that was
yeah i showed them how to make it it's
easy a little bit of lemon to keep it
from turning brown
mango says i make my own yeah yeah you
make your own we make our own too
sometimes yeah
you can just use if you don't have a
seasoning you can use just a little bit
of just standard
taco seasoning in it to cheat you know
but um there's a lot of recipes out
there you'll see now
the mexicans will usually blend it in a
blender and make it
smooth almost runny it's good
i prefer the california version i like
it kind of chunky yeah
california wakka sauce is chunky
it's just a mash you just me you dice an
avocado up
with maybe like a can of rotel some
seasoning a little bit of a garlic a
little bit of
lemon or lime and just kind of mash it
it's just slightly
you know a bunch of different ways you
can do it we do back there poop yeah
yeah but the blended that's how they do
it in mexico
uh i don't think it's as good as the
california one sorry unless
unless kanobotzlon can show me a recipe
of the blended stuff that i think beats
the california version
and mostly so far i think the mexican
versions of mexican food are better than
the cal mex and tex-mex
but i think california's got mexico when
it comes to
guaca sauce so far what are you doing
bob
catherine x says have you ever heard of
the fred and rosemary west case here in
england a few good years ago yes we have
uh we actually did that
on one of our valentine's day shows
because we did uh killer couples
and we might have done i think we did
fred and rosemary west on the same show
that we did
ian brady and myra hindley the moore's
murderers
i think man look at this what khan just
sent me some
shrimp ceviche and tuna he says the
heart jagger is going to the seafood
this is this is just a few minutes ago
down tijuana
that does it looks good looks very good
he's always showing me what he's eating
trying to make me jealous [ __ ] because
they eat good up there
they're down there mega says i like the
chunks too yeah it's really i don't know
i just like
it's just kind of like anything just
like i like chunky peanut butter rather
than smooth peanut butter it looks
like chunky in it it's gotta be chunky
you know
all right so can i finish this up
yeah finish it up all right finish it up
jen
all right so all right so at this point
like the investigators
uh asked ty if she would come back to
florida with them
and help them in the investigation and
uh
tai agreed at this point they really
wanted aileen to
confess to what she had done because
they thought that that would you know
bolster their case
obviously so they wanted um ty to help
them out
in that regard so what they were
planning on doing was that they were
going to install
tai in a motel in daytona beach
and uh since aileen was in jail on what
she thought was the weapons violation
like while they were investigating her
she's like well we'll have ty call you
um call her and like you know try to
make her
incriminate herself or try to make her
confess right
um because she's saying hey you know my
mom gave me money and i came down here
to get the rest of my stuff and her
story was that she was supposed to tell
aileen
that the cops were hounding her
and her family for the murders right so
they were kind of hoping to uh
trade upon aileen's uh warm feelings
toward tai
and that she wouldn't want ty or her
family to be harassed or she wouldn't
want tai to go to prison
for something that she had done so
that's
the angle that they were shooting at so
they actually kind of got
tied a call several times and they kept
talking and [ __ ] like that now
at first um the thing about it so
ty starts calling on january 14th right
uh 1991. now at this point as far as i
know
aileen still thought she didn't know
anything about the murders i mean
she didn't know that she was being held
for the murders she thought that she was
still just there under the
outstanding warrant the weapons
violation so
um you know so ty is trying to
get her to talk about the murders
but all aileen will say on the first
phone call is that she thought she was
only there for that concealed weapons
charge in 86 in a traffic ticket
um although she did kind of make
indirect mention to the
murders and said yeah i know about that
but i'm not one of their suspects
right the thing about it though is that
aileen seemed to be
pretty like hip to the [ __ ] so cause
like as soon as ty
like started talking about the murders
on the phone
aileen got suspicious that she was being
monitored or that she was which she was
uh so you know alien's not dumb
so she she kept asking her is you know
is there anybody else in the room with
you
like or is somebody listening to us or
something like that
um so she was suspicious from the
beginning and she wouldn't really say
anything that would incriminate herself
if she was gonna talk about the crimes
she always talked to him like real
she'd talk about him like real
cryptically like using code words and
[ __ ] like that
um because she uh
she figured and rightly so that someone
was
um monitoring the phone calls
and was listening to what she was saying
so she was kind of like hip to that like
from the beginning right
so they so ty keeps calling her
for several days right and then so ty
keeps like
kind of trying to like turn the screws
like look man like the cops are really
coming after me they're coming after me
they're coming after my family
and [ __ ] like that she's not saying
anything directly to aileen like hey
you know you need to confess to this
[ __ ] but she's just like man they think
i did it
and um you know they're really coming
after me and all this kind of [ __ ]
and in the end as suspicious as alien
was
uh that she was being monitored it did
actually end up working in the end
because she did actually
have enough feelings for tai to not want
her to go to prison
right so they were like you know so
they're talking on the phone
um and she basically after several days
of this back and forth
aileen says to ty over the phone she's
like just go ahead and let them know
what you need to know
what they want to know or anything i
will cover for you because you're
innocent i'm not gonna let you go to
jail
if i have to confess i will and she did
january 16th she actually came forward
and confessed to the murders um
ostensibly to keep tai from going to
jail
now interestingly so she she confesses
on january 16th
to um to a couple of the investigators
and the first thing that she wanted them
to know was like look ty didn't have
anything to do with this
um you know i did tell her about it but
she wasn't there she didn't
know anything she didn't have anything
to do with so leave her alone
um but another thing she started out
with she's like yeah i killed all these
dudes but
i killed them all in self-defense um
basically she was like every single dude
that she killed
which was seven guys if you're counting
um
had tried to rape her attack her
threaten her or something like that and
she wasn't having it
she got afraid and she shot them to keep
them from victimizing her
now as i said it seems reasonable to
assume
that the first dude she killed richard
mallory because like i said
you know they didn't even bring this up
at the trial but they found out later
that that dude was
a convicted rapist like a child molester
and so had the jury known that at the
beginning
maybe they would have gone a little
softer on aileen so i can totally
believe that maybe he tried some [ __ ]
and then she shot him like in
self-defense i buy that
um the other victims not so much because
i kind of feel like
after that she like you said
i don't know she necessarily got a taste
for it but she got to a point where she
was just on a hair trigger
one dude had done that um you know no
one was gonna do it again so you so much
as like sneezed or looked at her in the
wrong way and she was just gonna shoot
your face off
whatever you did you know what i mean so
i kind of feel like it got to that point
so i can buy that the first one was
maybe self-defense
the other ones i don't really i don't
know if i buy it you know what i'm
saying yeah they're talking about
mexican sauces in there let me jump in
if y'all in the comment kahn of otslam
from tijuana taught me a really good
[ __ ] sauce i want to tell you guys
about
you need an immersion blender it's like
a little wand with a [ __ ] rotating
blade
all right that's a good you can use a
regular blender but it's easier
if you have an immersion blender
get you a jar of jalapenos
with a ladle throw some jalapenos in the
bottom of a
can or a bowl or whatever you need
you're going to mix in it
you put some of the jalapenos in there
and then you
put a little bit of the jalapeno juice
in there also
you pour dried chipotle powder you can
get it in the spice section
if not a can of chipotle peppers
you put that in there and you blend it
together if it's too thin just keep it
adding dry chipotle into it
until it thickens and it'll turn into
like a bro into a dark red
paste a little bit thinner than say
hummus
it's smoky and real spicy if it's too
thick add a little bit more of that damn
jalapeno juice to it out of the jar out
of the jalapeno jar
fantastic especially once it's been
sitting for about a day in the
refrigerator
you want to make a lot of it at once
it's a really really good jalapeno sauce
a really good um chipotle salsa
that's and that's khan's family recipe
right there
[ __ ] swinging and you just told
everybody on me told everybody i gave it
to her and she's like yeah it's pretty
good
she doesn't like things that are hot
it's real smoky it's not real hot it's
more smoky flavored
like a smoked chipotle pepper
yeah got nice real nice yeah hot stuff
does not agree with me
anymore well it it never did to that
great
extent but especially now that i'm older
i can't eat anything
yeah i'll be suffering for two days
con's in there under the name heart
jaguar because his channel got [ __ ]
deleted
he's a heart jaguars who it is now he's
laughing because he's because the secret
is out
yes it was good i got a big jar of that
[ __ ] in the [ __ ] in
in the refrigerator that's my new go-to
it's like a salsa
real good they make
me hungry we're gonna have some hummus
after the show yeah we're done before we
go
home yeah because uh yeah that'll be
good right so
yeah so so basically she tells the cops
um yeah i killed all those dudes but it
was self-defense and she just was just
given so many details and [ __ ] like that
apparently her uh attorney who was uh
assigned to her he was a public defender
he basically said to her um do you
realize these guys are cops
you're just like doing their work for
them telling them all this information
and she said i know and they wanted to
hang me and that's cool
because maybe man i deserve it i just
want to get this over with
that's what she said she knew what she
did was bad
she knew you know what i mean so at this
point
because she's a woman serial killer a
predatory serial killer who killed
random ass strangers
which like i said is pretty much unheard
of
so this was a massively like all over
the [ __ ]
for sure all over the u.s i don't know
how widespread it went all over the
world but she got [ __ ]
book deals she got all kind of [ __ ] now
in florida
um you are not allowed like if you're a
criminal you're not allowed to profit
off of your crimes
you can totally write a book about it
but the money does not go to you
um usually it will go to the victim's
family or go to somebody else
they don't allow you to make money off
of the [ __ ]
um but there is no law against her
lawyers or her family members or
anything like that like profiting off
the crimes but so
a lot of them did get uh you know offers
and [ __ ]
um but yeah so she's just all over the
place and she
kind of seemed to get all into her being
famous
you know she was getting into the fame
so she just like
started talking her goddamn head off you
know um
and the more times she told
the story about what had happened and
all the people that she killed it seemed
like every time she told it
it would be more she kind of like
made herself seem more um
sympathetic each time i guess you know
what i mean like she would make it seem
more like
these dudes had a common kind of thing
yeah
which like i said i can buy it for the
first time
nah she got addicted to it it was just
but after that
i think it was easier to kill these
dudes than to blow them
well i mean in general that's true it is
easier to shoot a dude than to blow a
dude but i'm just saying that i think
i think like i said the first time
probably the dude did try to attack her
and she shot him and then like after
that she was just like [ __ ] it i'm just
going to say
this point of view she's gotta blow this
nasty [ __ ] right
and maybe she's gonna get 10 20 bucks
yeah why not just
kill and she got a swallow and
everything probably spilled it out it's
going to be in her [ __ ] mouth
why not just [ __ ] shoot the dude
and then take all his money yeah then
you get money
yeah and whatever else you got so you
might get 200 bucks
so you know that's what she did that's
why i don't have any sympathize
yeah the sympathy for like i said had it
just happened one time i might have had
sympathy but
she just kept on doing it nah she
obviously just killed the dudes for the
money
yeah i think after a time like you said
it just got easier
because she'd done it once yeah and you
know she's like well
she got sick of [ __ ] blowing these
dudes yeah it was a practical
consideration
she's just like well you know i'll just
kill him and take all their shits like i
wouldn't miss him and she's a lesbian
you know what i mean she's this is like
against her nature pretty much to do
this i kind of
sh i think she was bi she didn't really
start hanging out with women until she
was much older
yeah i think she's probably sick of
dudes by then she was [ __ ] lesbian
i think because she i mean she married a
dude initially
like she usually she had boyfriends and
[ __ ] like that but i do kind of feel
like
when she met ty then she kind of
discovered i think her
her upbringing and then a rough life
turned her against men
and then when she got into prostitution
i think that her [ __ ]
turning against men accelerated oh yeah
if you're working as a sex worker and
apparently like not to be mean but you
know somebody that looked like alien
mornings looked and you're in daytona
beach for christ's
you're sake to get some scuzzy looking
clientele right right
and so i understand that it would be
very easy to become disillusioned with
the entire
male gender right um because of the
examples of it
that you were dealing with from day to
day i understand that
it's a she her clientele [ __ ] was bad
i mean we know girls i i i'm not gonna
name them but we know girls
that are in the god scene that are
i guess you could say our sex workers
but they have a hard time getting jobs
because there's not enough clients
they're real picky
you know and they and they want quite a
bit of money
you know what i'm talking about right
yeah i'll show you what i'm talking
about
and all she does is constantly [ __ ]
basically e-bag
showing pictures of herself
and so you know in a very different i
don't think she's against
men you know what i mean
yeah not like eileen warren it's not
like there's a bunch of these nasty i
kind of feel like
just kind of hated everybody like i said
i kind of get that
because you know the way that she
grew up right was um
just appalling yeah and
she learned from a very young age not
only that you couldn't trust anyone
because everyone
sucked and would lie to you but also
that
selling your body for [ __ ] was the only
way to get any attention
that's the one i'm talking about yeah
okay
all right yeah makes sense now huh
cal state posting but yeah that's
you know like i said and i'm not
excusing what she did obviously because
she killed some people in cold blood
right i'm just saying that's probably
why she didn't do it for the same reason
that male serial killers do it is what
i'm saying
yes she killed strangers but and
no it wasn't entirely practical like yes
she did rob them
um did she enjoy it like in a sexual way
no
i don't think so i think she was just an
angry
person and she
toby's coming tonight oh awesome yeah my
leather daddy's showing up tonight oh no
i'm gonna get some video
of of me and toby [ __ ] [ __ ] around
oh that's cool
about that oh god i don't think i've
ever seen it before
we saw him at eyebar a few months ago
yeah
so now okay so listen to this weird [ __ ]
so she's in jail and she's pretty much
confessed to everything
although like i said from the beginning
she was kind of saying that it was all
self-defense that these dudes were all
trying to attack her in some way and she
just like shot him or whatever
but so she's sitting in jail and
she gets a letter from this woman named
arlene
pral prolly i'm not really sure how to
pronounce her last name she was 44 years
old
she was a born-again christian from
ocala running a horse boarding facility
so
you your mom might have known her maybe
back in the day oh this was it a long
time ago this was like 1991 1990s no she
was in brazil okay so probably not yeah
but she was in the same
industry that your mom was in so and it
was in ocala
so this woman said that she saw aliens
picture in the newspaper
um and wrote her a letter and the letter
starts my name is arlene pral whatever
name whatever however you pronounce it
i'm born again
you're gonna think i'm crazy but jesus
told me to write to you
yeah man jesus is always telling you
okay so she gives her the home phone
number
alien calls her um
on january 30th and apparently early
like jesus told arlene
allegedly that aileen was really a good
person
and that she needed an advocate and
somebody
you know to stick up for her so arlene
decided that that was gonna be
her um so
she starts visiting aileen and giving
her like advice on her defense and stuff
so aileen ends up she ends up firing her
old attorneys gets new ones
um arlene is out there talking with like
reporters and [ __ ]
um and then she's saying like weird ass
[ __ ] like
our souls are bound together like we're
like jonathan and david in the bible
which
like okay weird whatever um
and the saints like oh it's like part of
me is trapped in jail with her
um you know whatever so she's telling
everybody that she's really a good
person
that's like if everybody knew her like
she wouldn't get convicted
you know she's being railroaded or
whatever so it's just kind of like so
this kind of woman is out there in the
media like advocating on her
behalf so she's like in tabloids she's
on talk shows
all that kind of [ __ ] um so
at this point and put plus she brings a
lot of press into the prison like to get
aileen to talk to them like but only if
the press was going to be sympathetic to
her and would write a story
um you know kind of getting the public
to feel sorry for her
so that was kind of her whole schtick
granthus is in the damn comments he's a
[ __ ] 27-year veteran [ __ ] police
force he's saying
talking about yeah man looking the
hookers in detroit we're rolling [ __ ]
childs all the time
and this is let me tell you guys
something [ __ ] grandpa's to back me
up on this [ __ ] do not
[ __ ] with street hookers they take you
to some place to [ __ ] seal the deal
and sometimes her [ __ ] boyfriend's in
that location waiting for you pulls a
gun on you and takes your [ __ ] wallet
rolls you what do you do go to the cops
i was trying to seal deal with this
[ __ ] steal
seal the deal with this hooker and her
[ __ ] boyfriend robbed me you're not
gonna do nothing
well they know that that's why they do
it right because they know you're not
going to rip it if you're [ __ ] hard
up and you just [ __ ] can't get a
woman or you just want
save your [ __ ] money save up to you
got a grand and go
go down the [ __ ] strip club want to
[ __ ] or just buy a fleshlight for
crazy sake
porn stars porn stars [ __ ] do
porn is an advertisement for [ __ ]
professional services when they come
into town at the [ __ ]
strip club that's when you hit them up
for a grand you can get you can sleep
with your favorite porn star
this is how it goes well yeah that's one
of their um that's why she's there
go back to her hotel for a grand
maybe some other guys waiting for you
you know it's not gonna be just you
you know i mean this is a business you
know [ __ ] and her boyfriend's
probably gonna be there
her security what they're gonna call it
yeah
yeah so like i said this arlene woman
has given alien all this like advice and
[ __ ]
and then apparently there was this weird
thing where
i don't know if there was going to be
some kind of change or something where
arlene
and her husband were not going to be
able to visit alien anymore because they
weren't related
so at this point somebody like an
attorney or something like that said hey
well
if you adopt elaine warnos
um then you'll be related to her because
you'll be her parents
so you can visit her if you want to so
they did they adopted her
even though she was like in her 40s
which
i didn't know you could do that i
thought you could only adopt a minor
ridiculous
well no i guess because i guess like if
somebody's like old and they're like
mentally incompetent or whatever like
you can adopt
i guess you can do that if they're like
over there you're going to take that
you want to that way they can be in your
will i mean that seems like um
ripe for exploitation i'm just saying
but i guess they did let her do it at
least back then they let arlene and her
husband
and i don't even know like arlene and
her husband might have been the same age
as her
but they adopted her as their daughter
so they could come visit
i don't know it was really weird um and
i think arlene
said god told her too because that's
just what she did
so so basically they're going to have a
trial but arlene
uh or alien rather uh they got a plea
bargain
so she said um i'll plead guilty to
six charges because she actually um from
her confession she killed seven dudes
but they
one of the dudes they never found like
the body they never found so they
couldn't really charge her with that
so they were going to charge her with
six uh murders and she was going to get
six consecutive life term
life terms however there was one state
attorney
that thought that she should get the
death penalty
so what they decided to do because he
was so head up on her getting executed
was that okay we're going to put her on
trial for just one murder the murder of
richard mallory the first guy
um and if she gets guilty for that then
we can execute her for that and then
it'll be you know i mean because they
said if we try to do like all six it's
not gonna like work out the way they
want
um now interestingly at the trial
they didn't introduce anything about and
i'm not saying i'm not victim blaming or
anything like that but richard mallory
did have
uh several like prior convictions for
for rape uh and for you know child
molestation things of that nature
and that was actually not introduced at
the trial i don't know if it wasn't
allowed or if they didn't think of it or
they didn't know or whatever so that
might have
uh played a part in subsequent
events but it wasn't introduced at the
trial now but another thing that they
allowed you to do in florida at the time
because i know some states have
differing laws on this
sometimes if you're being tried for a
murder right
sometimes they're allowed to introduce
evidence of other crimes you committed
that you're not being charged
for at the moment um sometimes you can
introduce that
into evidence if it establishes a
pattern of behavior
right so because
they were only trying her technically
for one murder
however they were able to bring in
evidence of the other murders in the
trial
even though she wasn't being charged
with those because they didn't feel like
they had enough evidence in those
so the fact that between her being
charged with the murder of richard
mallory
and them not introducing anything about
his prior convictions
but also being able to bring in evidence
about all the other murders that she may
or may not have committed
um even though she wasn't being charged
with them at that time
uh pretty damaging another thing that
was very damaging and
was uh her defense attorney
um strongly suggested that she not
testify on her own behalf
um however she decided she was going to
do that [ __ ] anyway and in fact she was
the only
um she was the only uh witness on her
own behalf she was the only defense
witness and she didn't
make that good an impression to put it
mildly
she was um real
belligerent um she swore a lot
she you know she just really didn't make
a good impression on the jury she was
not
likable right and um
which which is why her defense attorney
told her please don't testify
but she did anyway um and that probably
ended up hurting her as well uh she
basically
kind of came on and was like she was she
was saying about how they had all raped
her and stuff and it just sounded
the way that she said it like just
sounded
not all that believable um and obviously
the
uh jury didn't believe her and all they
played a lot of tapes of her confessions
and stuff
and her confessions she was basically
talking about killing the dudes and she
didn't seem
um sorry about it she didn't seem
you know she wasn't repentant she wasn't
anything like that um
and so the jury were kind of like well
she just seems like
uh you know that that was just what she
wanted to do
and that she was kind of a piece of [ __ ]
um
she did say that she thought that she
deserved the death penalty because she
had killed people and she thought she
was a terrible person she
she does have she didn't have that much
uh self-awareness
they're asking what we're smoking it's
herbal cigarettes it's kind of like a
menthol it's real light kind of like a
tea
flavor it's nice yeah nice i can't smoke
cigarettes anymore i'll
easily i'm easily addicted to nicotine
yeah
i stopped [ __ ] a long time ago but i
haven't smoked in a while
it's nice though like vaping it's kind
of like david yeah these are i just got
these off
uh amazon because they didn't have any
so it's giving that smoky flavor you
know and you got the ritual
they don't have nicotine or anything in
them yeah but yeah so
uh so basically you know when she was
cross-examined
um you know he the cross-examiner like
it's funny because the dude uh he was
the prosecutor john tanner
and i remember that dude from the 80s
because i remember he was on this big
anti-porn crusade back then
and he was like always all over the news
back in the 80s like one just
cracking down on porn i just feel like
that was like all he was
i had totally forgot that he prosecuted
the alienware nose case because he was
i'm just like oh it's the porn guy
because that's all he was ever [ __ ]
talking about
because he was like some big [ __ ]
fundamentalist or something back when
they were worried about [ __ ] like that i
know funny a lot of bigger [ __ ] to worry
about that's all
that's like all i remember that's
because they didn't have the internet so
they saw something new it was shock him
well the thing about
it is that i kind of feel like dudes
like that allegedly
uh the more they're worried about porn
the more they're worried about child
porn [ __ ] like that the more they read
the more they're into it because
i think projecting it wasn't and a lot
of times that the guys
that were worried about it and going out
making money trying to prosecute it
they were doing it because they were
getting money from people who were even
older than them so it was like a grift
it was a great picture says what's the
brand they're called nerdosh
yeah they're good herbal cigarettes i
just got them off amazon
i just searched like earlier they
delivered them right to the house
they're not bad they're good
and they're cheap too i just i got a
couple packs for just like six bucks or
something
so uh so yeah so at this point like the
prosecutor like was not having it and
just like
kind of pointed out all her
inconsistencies and [ __ ] like that she
did take the fifth on a bunch of
questions
but you know as i said she really kind
of damaged her own case
as well like all the [ __ ] that she said
so um january 27th uh
the judge uh you know gave the case to
the jury
took the ver it took the jury less than
two hours
to find aileen warner's guilty of
first-degree murder
um and as they were leaving the
courtroom aileen screamed at them
i'm innocent i was raped i hope you get
raped
scumbags of america so you know look at
this [ __ ] a charming woman
zaneta said tom got me into the 80s goth
pretty good kind of like proto emo don't
you ever [ __ ] compare
goth to emo no
it's it was it goth was goth it was its
own thing [ __ ] emo was a temporary
little [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] that it was
not it didn't have anything to do with
emo we were laughing at emo when that
came out
like what the [ __ ] is that well [ __ ] man
i was like so old that like by the time
that came out that i was just kind of
like what is it what are these kids i'll
show you some more later on there's some
other good hair and skinny jeans
it was rock it was just before it was
called goth we
it was also called deaf rock
you know goth was a term that got
applied to it later
we we were doing it and didn't even know
it was called goth we was
yeah man it's looking like like a death
kind of rock
but there was also you know [ __ ] like
virgin prunes well that was around
already alien sex
fiend [ __ ] panther says it's the kyra
goth or emo
goth well they well yeah well because
they've been around well
they've been around since like [ __ ]
1978 so that's we didn't even know what
emo was back
yeah they never got although they
started they didn't know they were good
they started out as kind of like a punk
or a post punk fan yeah it was like joke
their early [ __ ] is kind of like post
bucky yeah
they went more laughing yeah they went
more gothy later on i thought
pornography is one of the guys
whatever yeah and that came out yeah
that's another one [ __ ]
senator if you like [ __ ] first and
last and always from sisters of mercy
go get the the cure an album called
pornography
that [ __ ] is the one of the darkest
albums it's
very much like the person lasting always
but just more intense almost with a with
a
hint of psychedela like a really dark
psychedelic to it
that was a [ __ ] really good album and
i think it predated that didn't it
by about two or three years yeah dated
first and last and always
really really good yeah pornography came
out in 82. 18. yeah first and last night
was 85 45 something like that i think it
was 85
yeah but i would think pornography was
one of the first albums that i would say
that's [ __ ] goth
now he's asking if nine inch nails is
gotham no industrial goth industrial i
kind of feel like that's more gotham
dangerous god than desperate
like i said i i saw 90s nails in [ __ ]
1990 opening for peter murphy when
nobody knew him yeah the
the first two bands that we noticed and
we knew it was a thing
was just what was was ba house and
skinny poppy skinny puppy was from
ontario
but they lived in detroit all right and
that was part of the scene that [ __ ]
when i'd
go to city club you'd you'd see
skinny puppy there and they'd play at
saint andrews hall and stuff
skinny puppy was like one of the very
first industrial bands it's like a
gothic industrial bed look
google skinny puppy bites
remission and that's an album it's two
albums combined together
and those two albums they first came off
separately bytes and then remission and
then they
released them together bytes and
remission and
um it is sounds like industrial music it
sounds like computers it isn't
it's dudes that have taken lifted bits
of
music and vocal tracks from old horror
movies like evil dead
and turned those into [ __ ] songs it's
all handmade
it's bizarre really good and that was
nine inch nails was kind of a copy of
that but they were using computers which
was cheating
that's kind of like when i first when
nine inch nails first came out
that's kind of what i thought that was
the first thing i thought was like ah it
kind of sounds like skinny puppy but
cheating yeah they're using
cheating computers i didn't mind them
though guinea pigs
made by hand i saw themselves they were
just using tape
skinny puppy and skinny puppy and
the very first um
okay you gotta understand that house
industrial and rap were all happening in
the same clubs the same time in detroit
um skinny puppy kind of used a lot of
the same tricks
that um [ __ ] um
chuck d and and uh public enemy they
were using a lot of same tricks public
enemy was
was using public enemy and skinny puppy
were kind of like two different
was the white version and the black
version but they were very similar
one was hip-hop and the other gangster
rap and the other one was
kind of like a dark horror sound really
cool
that's it yeah zenith said uh he liked
uh
skinny puppy and also lumpscott which
yeah
yeah yeah yeah uh yeah i also like
website yeah
and km fdm i asked yeah that was later
that was more
gothic techno industrial kinda yeah
no need for me too says disintegration
was 89 i think yeah
i think that came out like my last year
of high school so yeah that would have
been 89 or 9.
disintegration goths liked it but that's
not really
it i guess you could say it was good i
had got i bought that album and i liked
it but at that
point um i had kind of gone off the cure
a little bit because they were just well
they were getting to i liked that album
poppy but they were getting like too
mainstream at that point it was getting
kind of poppy by our standards
you know uh [ __ ] what was another
really good christian death with
with [ __ ] ross williams that was
another good one that was not not the
valor
not valor so much although i do like
that one song that
valor did but other than that i don't
then later on you had stuff like the
tier garden
or the legendary pink dots i liked them
they were good
um big into [ __ ] death in june
uh nature and organization and um
current 93 which was kind of like the
post-industrial gothic folk music which
was
bizarre you know a new version and a
more modern version of that would be
like uh
death in rome another good that's good
what else you got to say anything
anybody else talking well yeah i'm
trying to finish
the okay no i'm just like wait
stop talking no okay no so yeah so the
jury finds her unanimously
finds her uh guilty she gets all like
tells him they she hopes they get raped
so you know that's charming
um now they did actually have i guess at
the trial they did have some
psychiatrists
that testified on her behalf that were
kind of trying to
maybe mitigate it somewhat that said
that she suffered from borderline
personality disorder
which i i don't doubt that um she did
have a lot of the uh
symptoms of that um but the jury didn't
give a [ __ ]
and uh gave her a whole bunch of death
sentences
now she ended up she did she only stood
trial the one time and like i said that
was just for the one
murder the first one now march 31st of
that same year
she actually pleaded no contest to three
other murders
um saying she wanted to quote get right
with god
um now at this point cause like i said
when she was at the trial she tried to
say oh they all raped me it was all
self-defense
but um after she essentially
pleaded no contest to the rest of the
murders she said okay well the first guy
did try to rape me or did actually rape
her and then she killed him in
self-defense
the other ones started to but they
didn't get that far
so she was kind of saying okay with the
other ones weren't self-defense right
now um apparently so at this
hearing or whatever where she said that
where she essentially came out and said
yeah they weren't all self-defense just
the first one was
uh then she turns to uh the assistant
state attorney and says
i hope your wife and children get raped
in the ass so that's nice
um at that point she already had a
couple of death sentences she got three
more
uh at which point she just flicked it
flicked the judge off and still
called a [ __ ] so that's nice uh
month after that
she pled guilty to another murder uh
charles carlskaden
and uh got a fifth death death sentence
for that
and then she also in february of 1993
pleaded guilty to another murder walter
antonio um as i said so that was six
death sentences
she killed seven men probably but they
never did charge her for the death of
peter seams because they never did find
his body they just you know she just had
the car
thank you gadgey3 turns out all i needed
was some inspiration like mr miyagi but
a lot less
a lot less asian all right
thank you for the super chats people
this is the end of the month we know
y'all are broke
yeah that's awesome thank you we're all
broke yeah uh
yeah so um as i said you know the first
victim
you know later they found out uh that he
was
uh had actually served 10 years for
rape and various other things which they
didn't introduce at the trial
don't know if that would have made a
difference might have uh i don't know
but they didn't do a new trial
and at one point um you know because
when you're uh
on a death penalty case you get like all
the appeals right
um at one point alien said she didn't
want she refused further appeals she was
kind of just like [ __ ] this [ __ ] you
know just kill me i don't i don't give a
crap anymore
um i kind of feel like she had gotten to
the point where she was just sick of
being alive she was just sick of
fighting
so she actually got executed by lethal
injection actually at this point i think
in florida you could choose which is
[ __ ] up
you could choose between lethal
injection or electrical so
she chose lethal injection so she got
killed in october of 2002
that was more than a decade after she
murdered six men well seven but they
never did find the other body
so she got executed she was 46 years old
the tenth woman in the u.s
and the second woman in florida to be
executed since the death penalty was
reinstated in 1976 uh
so 51 men in that same time period 51
men had been executed
between 1976 and 2002. uh the other
woman
who was executed in florida if you're
curious was
judy buenawano um
she was uh also considered a serial
killer although
unlike aileen wernos she killed uh
people that she knew intimates she
killed some of her boyfriends a husband
a son other people like that she killed
people she knew she didn't kill
strangers
now famously aileen warnos's last words
were this is so weird she said
i just like to say i'm sailing with the
rock
and i'll be back like independence day
with jesus
june 6th like the movie big mothership
and all
okay i'll be back she's driven that's
what she said
which all right you know
so uh yeah so we uh mentioned earlier
that if you have not seen
the movie monster which i think about in
2003 right 2003
with uh charlize theron yeah and
christina ricci go see that [ __ ] because
that movie is
amazing yeah and um it's amazing like
these boobs are amazing
pretty see you can't i can't can't
resist them
it's 8 30 though is it yeah oh [ __ ]
we got to start getting ready oh man we
gotta get out of here all right good
shut this [ __ ] down jenny shut
it the [ __ ] down i feel bad because i
think louis just got here
louis just got here oh yeah he missed it
well as soon as you shut it down he'll
be able to go back and watch it
you can go back and watch it yeah
because like yeah seriously we're going
to the reason i'm dressed like this is
because we're going to
have a halloween party yeah which is
starting in about half an hour when he
said that was a boob spiral yes it was
well it would have been done a long time
ago if you were
i was supposed to get an amazon delivery
today so maybe it's that
but uh yeah so we have to get the [ __ ]
out of here because we got to go down
and
do some halloween [ __ ] halfway to
halloween [ __ ]
i'm glad i finally got through the
[ __ ] case no
you know yeah tom kept going off on
[ __ ] [ __ ] but whatever uh but yeah
so thanks everybody for dropping by as
always i don't know if i should wait
for time to come back so he can say bye
thank you victor good
show what is it is it stuff
okay is it stuff that's mine yeah yeah
oh my goodness
or something oh should i open it on
camera i don't know
shut it down we gotta go we gotta go we
gotta go i gotta put shoes on i gotta
put course on i gotta put nails on i
gotta do all kind of [ __ ]
all right so thank everybody for
dropping by thank you all for your
donations this evening and
we will see you guys on sunday
where we'll be talking about probably
the new creep show and maybe uh
brimstone treacle as well
yeah so have a good weekend
everybody and we will see you on sunday
afternoon
[Music]
bye